good
morning we're now going to open the
criminal justice Public
Safety
Committee call I'm going to call the
meeting to order we're now going to open
the public hearing on HB 1349 which is
decriminalizing The Possession and
use of
mushrooms before we begin representative
Marson do you want to lead us in the
Pledge of
Allegiance
to the flag of the United States of
America
the stands
na justice for
all
representative you do need to complete a
ping
sheet I would know how to use the
microphones
you push the button on the right when
the red light goes on so is your
mic if you're not recognized to speak
please keep your microphone
off
I never say anything inappropriate so it
doesn't matter to
me we we only would need one if we were
a quorum if we were going to have an
executive session so we would need to
have I think 11 members present in order
to have an executive session we have no
bills to exec so we're going to begin
with or without the majority well
large number of of the
people at this time I recognize the
representative Tony lebranch to testify
testify and offer um introduce HB
1349 let me take this off to begin with
thank you chair abis and thank you uh
criminal justice and Public Safety
Committee for allowing me to introduce
my bill today um I believe it's
important to start with definitions
before I introduce HB
um I know a lot of you probably already
know because this is the criminal
justice and Public Safety Committee what
the difference is between
decriminalization and
legalization in this case specifically
decriminalization means that we're not
putting people in prison for simply
possessing uh hallucinogenic uh
psilocybin mushrooms um there are many
reasons why this bill came to be and one
of those reasons is I don't believe it
is the role of government to tell people
what they can and cannot do in their own
homes hallucinogenic uh psilocybin
mushrooms have been found to be some of
the safest recreational drugs uh even
compared to alcohol and cannabis uh this
drug is safe um it it doesn't make sense
to me why alcohol should be legal when
this drug is safer um the cost of
incarcerating one individual in New
Hampshire is about $54,000 That's not
including Prosecuting them I believe
that the has better things to do with
that money and go after the dealers of
hard drugs instead of uh going after
individuals who simply possess and use
uh siloc cybin mushrooms um I don't
believe it is a crime in itself to
possess them um or should not be a crime
to possess them itself um we have seen
in other countries that have
decriminalized uh other drugs such as
Portugal which legalized or I should say
decriminalized every single recreational
drug drug addiction rates by 50% because
individuals felt comfortable to get the
help that they need without fear of
being prosecuted
um the use of drugs in itself is a
victimless crime uh especially when it
comes to mushrooms if you're using it in
your own home and you're not bothering
anybody else why should it be a crime H
so this bill specifically uh follows
what we did with uh marijuana in the
state of New Hampshire when it comes to
decriminalizing it and it follow the
same framework uh you can still be fined
for having mushrooms uh if you're
walking around in public or driving uh
but you will not go to prison at least
uh for your first three offenses and
that's what this bill does and I'm happy
to answer any
questions representative tesman you
recognized to ask a
question
rep representative board
n do you need the microphone turned on
is that I need to turn it
on
okay how many how many prosecutions or
arrests do we have for mushrooms per
year in New
Hampshire uh that is information that I
was not able to get from OSS but I will
say that even one prosecution that's
$554,000 to incarcerate plus the time
and money that we use to prosecute these
individuals uh there's there's better
resour or there's better uh things we
can do with those resources than
prosecute these individuals because we
should be going after the dangerous
offenders that are you know selling
heroin uh and and other hard drugs uh I
don't think that the the possession of
these uh relatively safe recreational
drugs is uh the way we should be going
in the state of New
Hampshire representative Roy thank you
thank you for taking my question um
you've made a a statement a couple times
about regarding the safety do you have
any uh studies or other evidence to
present to the committee that would
indicate how how safe these uh drugs are
it was my intent after this hearing to
send out an email with all these studies
that I have been collecting thank
you
representative
Balden hello thanks for taking my
question um in addition to whatever
you're planning to send to us can you
ensure that there's something that
specifically speaks to the claim that
it's safer than
alcohol that would be good to be able to
verify yeah there are multiple studies
that I can send out relating to the
safety uh of this drug follow Mr
chairman representative bolon recognize
for a followup um and additionally could
you send something about the cost to
incarcerate Yes uh that I found in the
fiscal note which uh stated that it cost
$54,000 uh a year to incarcerate
individuals in New Hampshire then I
already have that thank
you thank you repres oh representative
true you recognized thank thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
um I'm waiting through the bill can you
show me where in the bill it references
the uh Bine for three uh the third three
possessions
uh
decriminalizing third possession fines
where the fine what the fine
is uh it
is
here under 318 - B colon 2-f psilocybin
mushrooms uh if you go to uh section
four uh a it says that the first fine is
$100 the second offense under this
paragraph is $300 and any subsequent
offense and uh after three uh three
times of being caught with possession it
would be a three-year uh or it could be
a misdemeanor in this Cas thank
you
thank you
representative you're
excuse this time the chair now
recognizes Ian
Freeman
good
morning I'm here to speak in favor of
this bill as a minister with the shy
Free Church you're going to hear I'm
sure a lot in emails or various
different testimony that might be sent
to you about the safety of uh psilocybin
mushrooms and they are indeed very safe
Professor David nut who is the former
basically drug Zar of the UK came out
with a chart back in 2010 that measured
the relative harm of each drug that is
prohibited and in his case he was in the
UK but they still prohibit most of the
same drugs that are prohibited here in
the United States and it's a very
comprehensive list with alcohol and
drugs they categorized harm based on the
harm to the individual user and also
harm to Society at the very bottom
of
the list is psychedelic mushrooms which
is what we're talking about here it's
actually lower on the list of harm than
cannabis which has as you know already
been decriminalized here in New
Hampshire as of 2017 and the you know
New Hampshire hasn't caught on fire as a
result of that so everything's okay uh
this bill goes in that same direction uh
P psychedelic mushrooms are also
therapeutic um there's plenty of studies
there's a mount
of studies that have been built on this
it has helped people with PTSD with
depression many military veterans have
uh actually solved their PTSD through
the use of psychedelic mushrooms where
no other treatment has been able to do
that these things are natural and I
shouldn't have to point out the
absurdity of criminalizing nature of
making it illegal to have something that
grows
naturally and it's something something
that people humans have been using for
thousands of years all across the planet
but the one thing I really wanted to
focus on today is the fact that if you
guys pass this bill and you
should you're actually just going to be
following along with what the you uh
what the New Hampshire Supreme Court has
already decided uh distributed I want to
bring your
attention to the Supreme Court of New
Hampshire a case that was issued in
December of last year it is called State
of New Hampshire versus Jeremy Mack m k
Mack Mr Mack is a member of the oaka VHA
if I pronounce that correctly uh
psychedelic church it's a Native
American church out of uh the west and
he was arrested for possession of
psychedelic mushrooms in New Hampshire
was convicted at Superior Court he
appealed his case the New Hampshire
Supreme Court ruled unanimously to
overturn his conviction the New
Hampshire Supreme Court said and I'm
summarizing here uh 22-page opinion but
basically that New Hampshire's
Constitution actually goes further than
the US Constitution which one of the
things we love about New Hampshire where
you know we love freedom here uh the New
Hampshire Constitution protects people's
right not just to religion but their
right to work worship and obviously the
Supreme Court of New Hampshire agreed
again
ruling unanimously to overturn this
man's conviction for possession of
mushrooms and just you know it's just a
couple of sentences I'm going to read it
to you uh this is from the New Hampshire
Constitution it says every individual
has a natural and unalienable right to
worship God according to the dictat of
his own conscience and reason and no
subject shall be hurt molested or
restrained in his person Liberty or
estate for worshiping God in the manner
and season most agreeable to the dictat
of his own conscience or for his
religious profession sentiments or
persuasion provided he doth not disturb
the public peace or disturb others in
their religious worship so if you're at
home or you're in a safe place which is
of course the best place to do a
psychedelic of any sort is a safe
setting then you're not disturbing the
public peace and so according to the New
Hampshire Supreme Court that's legal
here in New Hampshire so the statutes
against this need to be changed to catch
up with this Supreme Court case um happy
to give this to whoever needs to get it
if you want to get copies out it's like
20 pages so with that I'm happy to take
any questions oh one other thing I do
feel as though this bill is a good step
in the right direction but It ultimately
doesn't go far far enough um what it
should be done is there should be an
amendment put forth to actually
decriminalize all natural things so not
just mushrooms but there's other you
know things that grow on Earth that are
also prohibited and those should be
included in this but as is it's pretty
good I support it so happy to take
questions representative
Rory thank you uh chairman thank you for
taking my question sure um you
referenced the uh military PS
PTSD are you aware whether or not if the
VA has experimented and used this as a
treatment officially for veterans I am
not that's an excellent question but
there have been a growing number of
studies with larger and larger sample
sizes that have been coming out over the
last couple of decades uh the FDA has
been authorizing these uh these studies
to become larger and larger so we're
starting to finally see some of the
really interesting applications for
therapeutic use of drugs like
psilocybin follow representative Roy
thank you um similar to to cannabis
regardless of um what we decid to do is
this would still be uh illegally
federally correct well of course that's
that's correct um the federal system is
slow to change even slower than than the
one here in New Hampshire however of
course we've seen as cannabis has been
legalized and decriminalized across the
country the federal government has been
reticent to really put a heavy hand down
on the states uh that have moved in this
direction so I wouldn't worry about them
in this
case thank you representative tman thank
you thank you for taking my question
certainly you were reading that decision
it seemed to allude to a person
practicing
religion so do you have to get a
certificate
of your practice of religion to to use
these drugs I mean I I how do you
separate the two well in Mr Mack's case
uh he did have a membership card for the
okoa church I don't think you should
have to have a membership card to prove
that you have a religion I mean
ultimately as long as you have a
religious belief and you're willing to
assert that uh these things are very in
my opinion in my experience very
spiritual practice practice so the use
of psychedelic mushrooms goes back for
many many thousands of years for
Spiritual um reasons recognize for a
followup
but you based a lot of your testimony on
the religious clause in the
Constitution how do you tie that to a
person who is not
religious and the use of of this drug
not disagreeing whether it's right or
wrong I'm just saying you tended to tie
them together and I'm not sure that's
logic well you're certainly correct that
people's reasons for using uh these
things differ okay so a religious use is
going to be different than somebody who
wants to take a drug at a party or
something like that um but either way
it's immoral to put somebody in a jail
cell for doing something to their own
body just on a fundamental basis now
there's more responsible ways to use
these things and there are irresponsible
ways to use these you should not get
behind the wheel of a car for instance
uh while doing this so being in a safe
set in setting is very important and in
my
experience the use of psychedelic
mushrooms this isn't a party drug for
the most part this is a very
introspective experience you're much
more likely to not want to talk to
people you're much more likely to want
to go inside deide oneself and look at
yourself and look at your experience in
life and it's just not it's not a party
drug generally but even if somebody were
to take this set a party that should not
be a criminal act and it just doesn't
make sense to spend taxpayer dollars to
put that person behind bars it's not
helping
anyone if I may inquire with a question
thank you for taking my question in in
the bill it has a possession limit it
would it would be 12 grams
approximately how many doses would that
be that's good question uh a very strong
dose of mushrooms is probably about
three and a half grams uh generally
considered to be what they call an
eighth of an ounce so 12 grams would be
enough to you know have a few different
doses on hand in your house and that
seems like a reasonable uh limit
obviously I'm not in favor of any kind
of limits or any kind of drug
prohibition at all but we have to take
you know it's it's politics you have to
take steps and this is a good step in
the right direction thank
you representative
Lang thank you Mr chair I I guess my
question is I know when we having a
marijuana discussion they talking about
marijuana is not sure marijuana of the
70s or 60s anymore that um it's been you
know modified and grown through various
reasons to increase potency can the same
thing be done with mushrooms are we just
talking about you know is there are
there ways of enhancing potency and does
that have any different
effect that's an interesting question I
mean mushrooms are such a a strong uh
experience I it's a very uh it can be a
lifechanging experience to to take
mushrooms so what science can do what
technology can do to modify that um I
can say this I have come across a liquid
psilocybin in the in the black market
and it's very interesting because
generally when someone takes mushrooms
one of the downsides of of dosing on
mushrooms is that you might puke um it
it can be a very upsetting experience if
you have any food in your belly at the
time there's a good chance that's going
to come up so it's usually best to take
it on a on an empty stomach the liquid
product actually gets rid of that
problem so there have been some
technological developments that make it
actually easier for people uh to take
this and and have a better overall
experience follow up Mr J follow up Mr
chair you're you recognized thank you so
again um does that alter
you know in any way your thoughts on
legalization is if if if we allow for
this generic ver conversation of
psilocybe pilocytic mushrooms in in
making it stronger and and dealing with
you know again alterations of of nature
so to speak to make it more potent does
that have any impact on your thoughts on
legalization actually I think that this
development of the liquid that I
mentioned to you is a really positive
development because when you normally
are going to take a dose of mushrooms
you really have no idea the potency uh
you can when you look at them you can
say well this one's bigger than the
other one but it may or may not have
more psilocybin in it and ultimately
that's the chemical that we're talking
about here that is uh the Psychedelic
chemical or the entheogenic chemical so
you can't just weigh three and a half
grams and say oh well this is going to
be a good dose it could be the strongest
dose you've ever had in your life or it
could be incredibly weak you just can't
tell one one to the next but the liquid
version
you can actually measure the dose very
accurately and so that allows someone to
be very sure and very certain uh the
level of an experience that they're
going to have which has been previously
unavailable in uh in the black market so
that's a technological advancement that
is very very good for people because if
you want to there's something that's
been more popular recently called micro
doing uh where it got kind of popular
out in Silicon Valley with tech people
where they would take a very small dose
of a of a psychedelic like mushrooms
maybe a tenth of a standard dose and
they would be able to go to work and
they'd be able to be productive and they
wouldn't want to like curl up in a ball
and you know uh go inside themselves it
was a much different more productive
experience for them so to be able to
measure a dose means that it can be used
in a much more medicinal fashion so I
think that actually is a positive
development representative Roy thank you
uh thank you for taking my question
again sure is is it possible to overdose
onde there has never to my knowledge
similar to cannabis ever been someone
who has uh died from overdosing on
psilocybin I mean any amount of this
thing is a strong experience I mean if
you take a a normal size dose so there's
a natural tendency to not want to do
that because it's very strong in general
thank
you thank you for your testimony thanks
for listening
is there someone I should give this to
sport case secretary or something can
you can you can hand hand it up
in this time the chair recognizes
Lieutenant William
brigh good morning uh for the record my
name is Lieutenant William or Bill brigh
um with New Hampshire State Police I
overse the uh narcotics unit uh of the
State Police um I'm here to represent
the State Police in our opposition to
this bill um and that is simply for the
public safety risk that uh we believe it
it would entail um in general
decriminalization of a uh drug will lead
to Greater use uh some
experimentation um which will also lead
to some uh more and frequent impairment
in public uh by way of uh you know on
our road roads driving um exposure to
Children um and just general public
intoxication um you it was mentioned in
the in the previous testimony that
there's no idea uh no way to judge the
potency um of a dose of a
hallucinogen um which I think is is
something that uh should be of
concern because it's unpredictable uh
hallucinogens are unpredictable uh By
Nature as as far as the reaction that
somebody will have when they take one or
try one um which could lead to making
poor decisions um as well as um just the
the general exposure to
um to the children in our in our
community I I know from from my
experience my children have told me that
there are already uh hallucinogens or
shrooms in the schools that they that
they're that they are in um which is is
concerning to
me um it's also said it was also said in
the previous testimony that um you know
use uh by somebody in their own home um
that would be great if that was the case
all the time but uh in general that that
will not be the case if it's easier for
somebody to possess uh psilocybin
mushrooms it's going to be easier for
somebody to use that in public and it
won't won't always be taken in a safe
manner with no way to to regulate the
dosage levels uh that somebody uh takes
we just have a concern for the public
safety risk that's my testimony and I'm
willing to take any questions
representative Roy thank you Mr chairman
um thank you lieutenant for taking my
question are you aware is there any type
of a um a test that an officer could
administer a field part of a field
sobriety test to tell if someone was
under the influence of these uh drugs
nothing that I'm aware of for
specifically for uh
um obviously we can do uh impairment
tests just like we do with with alcohol
or with marijuana or any other drug um
we have drug recognition experts that
are at times able to determine um what
type of drug it appears that somebody is
impaired with um but I'm not aware of a
specific test for suicid followup
please thank you so it would be safe to
say that if somebody were under the
influence of these it would be um
impossible to tell exactly what was
affecting them other than the educated
guest from an officer to my knowledge
yes thank
you representative
Newman along the lines of the question
that was just asked um how big of a pro
I don't want to call it a problem how
often do Law Enforcement Officers run
into things where these types of
mushrooms are involved in my experience
and I haven't been uh I haven't been on
patrol for about 10 years but in my
experience um over the 20 years that
I've been in law enforcement I I have
not seen it often um but I do uh as I
said as I said before I mean I know my
my own children have told me that that
they've seen these at maybe not
personally seen these but know that
people are are using them children in
the
schools representative
Newman and do you have any insight you
might give us based on conversations or
things you know about other people or
just in general what you might think the
how often this is a problem in the state
or anything like that I don't have any
specific uh any specific thoughts on
that um but I would just say that in
general if if this is decriminalized or
legalized how whichever term you want to
use um
there will in our experience there will
be more experimentation there will be
more use which will lead to a greater
public safety
risk thank you for your testimony thank
you this time the chair recognizes
Bonnie
Krauss
hello my name is Bonnie Cruz I'm an
activist and volunteer from Kean New
Hampshire I found a decriminalized
nature in New Hampshire with my friends
because I have personal experience with
en theogenic plant medicine and I
believe it is the answer to so many
problems facing our community New
Hampshire today we're living in a time
of extremely high rates of anxiety
depression addiction and
suicide and medical practitioners are at
a loss trying to find things that can
help people entheogenic plants and fungi
such as psilocybin have been showing
promise in studies and therapeutic
office settings around the country
already many military veterans who have
come back from Wars with severe PTSD
have found that only anthens such as
siloc cybin can help them such as uh
Adam Kes from Arizona uses s cbin and
gives it to other military vets uh with
his church legally um helps uh he helps
vets that are suffering all around our
country Justin O'Donnell from here in
New Hampshire he contacted this
committee via email and he's also a
veteran in favor of this bill people
contacted are contracted by the
government to put their lives on the
line for the government in Wars like my
dad and Grandpa should at the very least
not be stopped in the state of New
Hampshire from getting the medicine they
need for their
trauma this bill ought to pass because
it will directly relieve Granite Staters
from the trauma of being punished by the
court system for simply possessing
psilocybin mushrooms possessing and even
dosing yourself with psilocybin hurts no
one and is therefore not a crime our
ancestors used this medicine for
thousands of years
safely alcohol is legal to possess in
the United States and many of us have
seen its ill effects you don't really I
don't believe that we need that many
studies showing its ill effects
everybody in this room has probably seen
at least somebody throw up from using
alcohol and make bad decisions but
decriminalizing it did make it safer or
you know legalizing it's legal it did
make it safer than when people were
making bathtub batches and moonshine and
that's what decriminalization will do
for cbon as well the
lieutenant um suggested that it's going
to make
um the whole state less safe because it
will be more widely used but really if
it's not um people aren't being gone
after for possessing it then the problem
that Ian Freeman and the lieutenant
mentioned of dosing can actually be
fixed without people being afraid of
going to jail for that
I've seen Cil cbon positive effects and
I'm asking you to please pass this bill
to decriminalize it thank
you representative Roy thank you
chairman thank you for taking my
question um the bill talks about
legalizing or not legalizing
decriminalizing the possession of it
um the problem is is that the dealing of
it would still be the selling of it
would still be illegal where would one
go go to get
psilocybin and know that it's
safe
well I don't really know the answer to
that I don't I didn't see in the bill
anything about um the sell of it okay
all right thank
you thank you for your
testimony this time the chair recognizes
representative Kevin
verville
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee good
morning I don't know how many of us know
the history of psychedelics um I know
some of it and
so psychedelic mushrooms cacti other
substances have been used for thousands
of years by humankind uh safely and
effectively Dr Albert Hoffman working
for sandas in Europe uh synthesized LSD
for the first time in the
1950s in fact sandas commercialized
LSD as delit and you can still find the
brochure
online so cybin masculine LSD they're
all very closely related it was the
advice of sand pharmaceutical to
doctors to administer a
dose for therapeutic use and to double
the dose each session until uh the
desired effect was
obtained so it's very interesting dosing
recommendations in fact the US
government became very interested in
psychedelics particularly the military
CIA
fortunately their desires were uh truth
serum and population
control the
experiments were abandoned and the
position on psychedelics was reversed
when it was discovered that users of
psychedelics become
pncks and in the 1950s and the
1960s the US government for various
reasons was not interested in turning
average citizens into what we would now
classify as peac Nicks psychedelics were
first made illegal in the United States
by Democrat governors of Western States
namely Nevada and then
California and that was a knee-jerk
reaction to Growing public interest in
psychedelics at the time the federal
government quickly followed suit with an
Iron Curtain against all psychedelic use
and medical use personal use um and
research in fact Federal research on
psychedelics has only uh come back in
the last few
years these compounds are essentially
considered to be non-addictive and for
the record so I support the bill in case
you haven't figured that out I should
have led with
that I believe in the decriminalization
of most if not all psychedelic compounds
I am not a general legalizer of drugs I
don't believe that amphetamines I don't
believe that barbituates I don't believe
that opiates I don't believe that other
compounds should be legal and the reason
I don't believe that is because I
believe that there are more drugs what's
a more drug you ask a more drug is a
drug that the more you do the more you
want to do they're highly addictive and
uh essentially destroy lives
psychedelics do not fall within that
classification ation we've already heard
testimony on the therapeutic use so I
won't uh I won't beat that up I'd like
to to thank the previous speaker for
making note to the committee that
prohibition does not
work in fact if your uh finger is on the
pulse of American Youth and older people
psychedelics are currently in a
Renaissance in the United States
psychedelic use people in about the
1980s in the United States and we are
slowly uh approaching those levels again
because of the renewed interest
prohibition does not work if there are
psychedelic mushrooms in the
schools then that tells you everything
you need to
know the challenge that we have is that
we're producing
felons young AG felons if you get caught
with psychedelic mushrooms with C and
mushroom if you get caught with peyote
which contains masculine or if you get
caught with LSD in any form and you get
convicted you are a
felon that is very bad
policy because there are no other crimes
other than possession that are typically
associated with the use of
psychedelics
right I think we all agree that we want
young people to be able to approach law
enforcement as well as the criminal
justice system in an open and honest
fashion I want my kids I want your kids
I want all kids to feel like they can
approach the police for help if they
need
it and if I've got a bag of mushrooms in
my
pocket I can't do that because if the
situation takes a turn that's
unpredicted and I have to empty my
pockets and I'm convicted I'm a felon
and that destroys my
life growing up I didn't trust the
police and that haunted me for years of
my
life because I didn't realize
why and the reason why is because I made
lifestyle
choices that essentially made me a
non-convicted
felon right I should not have had to
fear the police if we want to heal that
relationship between young people young
adults because those are the primary
users one of the steps we should make is
to
decriminalize most
psychedelics this is a step in that
direction this is common sense
bipartisan legislation I took some notes
so the dosage question dosage question
question is very very
interesting psychedelic mushrooms or
micology it's a study of
fungi to the best of my knowledge nobody
has been
successful in um selective breeding of
mushrooms to increase the potency of the
mushroom various psilocybin mushrooms by
strain contain various amounts of
psilocybin and typically users know
which is which and we'll we'll go
shopping we'll choose product for a
given
effect not on the table today but
interesting to to
consider that the dosage of most LSD on
the street is considerably lower today
than it was in the
1980s it's it's anecdotal I I can't give
you the I can't give you the scientific
research that that shows that the dosage
of blot acid goes down but if you're
familiar with users from then and now
and you interview them you'll know that
to be a fact so interestingly the dosage
for psychedelics has been going down and
in fact one of the biggest things in
Vogue today is to micro do is to not
take the large uh dose for the very
heavy introspective effect but rather a
very smaller dose to try to uh encourage
creativity of of the
Mind the development of liquid
psilocybin or psilocybin carried in a
liquid form is not a new
development Dr hofman Who We heard about
earlier was also successful in
synthesizing psilocybin uh in the late
1950s so synthetic psilocybin has been
known for a long time it is to the rest
of my knowledge never been
commercialized because the production of
uh mushrooms of fungi is uh much much
easier to to do and that has has been
the the
effect I don't know it for a fact for S
ayin I would have to double check but
LSD a very close relate relative of
psilocybin you cannot repeat you cannot
overdose on LSD and I believe that is
true for psilocybin and I will try to
find the reference for that and get it
to the committee right remember that you
cannot
overdose on LSD and I believe it's true
for
s in the United States it's very easy to
produce these mushrooms both indoor and
outdoor and the possession of spores
which is essentially the seed is not
illegal repeat the possession of
psilocybin mushroom spores or the seeds
is not illegal because the spores do not
contain psilocybin they do not contain
the active so it it's virtually
impossible to stop the the
production previous speaker spoke of
Public
Safety when people have to
hide and people fear getting help they
may need for whatever
reason you put the public at far greater
risk under those
conditions than you do by
decriminalizing a compound that's in
use that's in our society that's readily
available right I don't think miners
should be doing this but they are and we
shouldn't do anything that that puts
them at risk I would strongly encourage
that this committee pass this bill so
that we can decriminalize suicide and
mushrooms as a step in the right
direction if we think about other bills
that we've passed other laws that we've
changed this is this is going to be akin
to that when we pass constitutional
carry there were cries there were going
to be shootouts in the streets never
happened when we decriminalized
marijuana in New Hampshire pot use is
going to run rampant Society was going
to collapse it never happened right
this bill will have same
effect thank you for your time and I
would be more than happy to take any
questions any member of the committee
may
have uh thank you representative um I'm
gonna first uh recognize myself for a
question um setting aside the the policy
issue of whether or not we should make
this legal or IL legal from a logistical
mechanical standpoint we know that um
many drugs are um are sold that have
been laced or tainted or for example
we're having trouble with with um with
fentanyl um being introduced into
certain drugs and the user not knowing
it and
overdosing and whether or not the point
of you can overdose or not the question
I have is mushrooms in themselves some
of them are extremely
lethal how would someone know that they
were getting a a safe product if we make
this
legal and there are people dealing it
and and someone buys it and they end up
getting something that's poisonous I
mean where would where we didn't we're
not the bill doesn't speak to
distribution it only speaks to
possession so how can we ensure Public
Safety if the dealing of it still
illegal so it would be black market and
and like I said some mushrooms are
extremely lethal even tiny doses so how
can we ensure that people aren't getting
which is already happening with other
drugs something that they didn't
intend that is a fantastic question Mr
chairman I I appreciate
it some of you might have deduced that I
follow this subject rather rather
closely I am not
aware of any incident
where any psychedelic substance was
adulterated with any other
material so I would challenge anybody
that would allege that that is a
possibility not a possibility but a but
a problem to find one instance in the
United States where that has occurred
but our focus is a little more narrow
and it's psilocybin mushrooms right and
there's an old wives tail out on the
street the more blue the more potent the
mushroom that's not
true but these mushrooms when bruised do
turn a very blue color they have a
relatively uh unique appearance uh and
all um psilocybin mushroom strains
appear more or less the same and are
relatively easily
identifiable the it's my belief
that the producers as well as the users
of
psychedelics are not
motivated U by profit it's not they're
not in it for the money and so when we
look at things like heroin and and
cocaine maybe to a lesser extent things
like methamphetamine those drugs are
being adulterated with cheaper compounds
less expensive compounds that require
less to be added and the street price
Remains the Same so it's to drive up the
cost soloc cyb and mushrooms
LSD on the open market are very
inexpensive drugs because the producers
dealers and the users are not interested
um in in the financial aspects I mean
everybody makes the money um but I don't
I don't see that as an issue I I I've
never known anybody to get a fake
mushroom now there are some
hallucinogenic mushrooms that that grow
naturally in New Hampshire right uh
panel is there's another another type I
only know them by the common name
laughing gyms and and those are not
those are not criminalized compounds
because they don't have the the solide
so there are other naturally occurring
mushrooms in New Hampshire that one can
take for position effect I hope I
answered your
question thank you um um representative
Bert thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for taking my question um I'll be very
impressed if you know this answer so I'm
asking if you could find out this
answer when Nevada California followed
by the federal government banned this
who were the
lobbyists behind the Banning of this
because I know like with the marijuana
it was the alcohol lobbyist that wanted
marijuana um so if you do know that'd be
great if you do know so and I do have a
followup thank you thank you
representative it's a good question so
certainly um Federal
authorities um particularly military and
intelligence had soured on psychedelics
that they were researching so MK Ultra
right was the program of psychedelic
research and and you can you can Google
that and and and learn uh all about that
the the governors I think were
mostly motivated
so so the genie got out of the bottle
feds were testing they had loose
controls and their test subjects found
out with what they were being dosed
figured out that if you can acquire
lysergic acid you can produce lysergic
acid diethyl amid um quite readily quite
inexpensively and because it turned
people into pings because of The
Experience under psychedelics that the
vast majority of people have there
becomes this Evangelistic Drive in some
people to spread the word that if you
take this you will see the universe for
what it is you will understand the
universal Oneness and you will
understand we are all related we are all
brothers and sisters and we are not just
related as people but but as as
everything we are essentially the
universe trying to to realize itself
that's The
Experience mass production began in in
in Labs you know street street Labs a
bad name right because the the purity of
the material was very very high and so
there were things called acid tests
where um if a if somebody chose to go
you know you take a small cup of the
Kool-Aid and and you have the experience
um it the peace generation the anti-war
movement was was really getting jined up
it was tied to the psychedelics and so
it was really I think an attempt at
Governor's um for a a law and order you
know can we just get back in line and go
back to uh pretending it's 1958 again I
think was a was a very large driver and
there was a huge
misunderstanding of uh what psychedelics
are what they do and how they how they
work I I can look into it but I can't at
this point I can't guarantee that that's
readily available thank you in a
followup Mr chairman thank you Mr
chairman um you know because I always
wonder you know I always follow the
money so you know usually something's
banned because somebody wants to make
money somewhere El it's like alcohol um
now the lieutenant said that uh that
testified said that his own children you
know didn't see any and has never taken
it that's good uh but said that it is in
their
schools uh how available is it in the
school you know is it equal to marijuana
which I heard is just rampant in
schools so I would tend to tend to agree
that marijuana uh cannabis products are
very readily available particularly at
the particularly at the high school
level it's my understanding from Reading
you know news reports and and following
uh what's going on the United States is
in a psychedelic
Renaissance um these these things are
are fairly easy to to obtain um a lot of
people have have used them uh there's
certainly people in this room right now
that that have used them uh to know no
ill effect and uh and and simply want
to stop the possibility of making felons
the last LSD rest I heard of in New
Hampshire there was a couple of kids in
Manchester there was a boy and a girl on
a date High School aged they chose to
hang out for whatever reason in a
cemetery they were in the car just
hanging out together having their
experience the police noticed a car in
the cemetery after dark they went they
investigated somehow they found a few
hits of blotter acid on on the young man
and uh he went to jail he's a felon for
life right and they weren't they weren't
doing it they picked a bad spot to to to
be because they felt they had to hide
right and and so those those lives are
ruined and and this bill is to try to to
try to fix
that um and that's why I that's why I
support this this this bill the the only
amendment I would offer to this bill
would be to add LSD and and siloc
mesculin uh to the list but but again
maybe that's a bite too far today and so
I think this is a good first step in the
in the right direction thank you
representative thank you
uh representative
Balden thank you thanks for taking my
question um I'm sorry if you already
covered this but um what's your
perspective on uh changing the bill to
make the h21 do you think there the
drawbacks there because based on the
story you just shared do you think that
the drawbacks are greater than maybe
some of the benefits as far as um the
pass the legislation thanks for taking
my question
thank you for the question it's an
excellent question right and so the
question is you know what step in the
right direction can we
take
adults particularly when you get up into
your 30s 40s you know 50s like
me you you learn how to live within a
system that may not approve of what you
do and and you can take prudent action
to avoid trouble
young people are not as Savvy at doing
that right I mean we all know the joke
of the the drug deal in the hallway oh
look you know they're they're exchanging
pot I let's not kid ourselves we know
what that looks like they think they're
being discreet and they're not they're
actually drawing attention to themselves
this bill doesn't
directly help those
people it
doesn't probably 18 would be a a better
better age um I think the prosecution of
minors with psychedelics you know is is
probably a little lower um I'm not an
expert in that
but the bill probably would be better
with no no age specified but I think
that that would probably be um found to
be unpalatable because of the belief and
I think it's a misconception I don't
believe there's any truth to it that if
you did that that all of a sudden you
know eight-year olds and 12y olds would
start taking psychedelic mushrooms
most people are very apprehensive about
taking these compounds particularly for
the first
time because of the
lies lies that have been told about
these compounds for
decades when I was in high school when
they gave us our drug education
program they made it sound like if you
you took a psychedelic once you know you
you stood a good chance of ending up in
what used to be the New Hampshire state
hospital for the rest of your life right
that simply is not true I mean can you
find a case here or there where somebody
has an adverse reaction yes but that's
true with almost anything but the vast
majority of users that is not true and
most people I I believe begin to
experiment with these compounds um in
the high school years typically the
second half um and so that age group is
is selected out I I would prefer to pass
something that we can pass to allow the
data to be collected that making this
change does no harm right this bill will
do no harm and then once we see that we
can look at perhaps expanding uh depth
and breadth of the legislation if that
answers the
question follow
up thank you
um it seems like you obviously have a
personal connection with the subject
matter um and a lot of your commentary
has been sort of um
ideological do you have any commentary
on the fiscal impact of passing this
legislation yeah that you know
that's that's not my baileywick to be
quite Frank um I I think the fiscal
note's pretty clear it's expensive to
make somebody a
felon possessing psilocybin mushrooms
and to throw them into the state prison
for any period of time or or any other
place where they're they have to be
monitored or or they're incarcerated is
expensive and in my opinion there is
absolutely no value no value in that to
society or the state and so this this
bill I believe this bill is a harm
reduction bill for the General Public
public and I think it should be passed
and I hope that answers your
question um uh I going recognize myself
for another question if if you don't
mind representative um with when I asked
this earlier with regard to the the the
contradiction between state and federal
laws even if we were to make this um
decriminalized in New Hampshire it would
still be a federally legal substance and
there a lot of ramifications for that
long term for young people um so if a
young person does s the cbin um he would
be automatically uh disqualified from a
lot of different careers in their future
anything um that required a security
clearance in the military he would never
get um he'd be disqualified from serving
in law enforcement where the polygraphs
administered um so there there's a lot
of long-term effects with breaking a
federal law even if it's not illegal
here what are your thoughts thoughts on
that that contradiction and the impact
that could have on young people that
they don't realize down the road they've
just ruled out a whole whole set of
career field potentials that's an
excellent question and I agree with the
previous speaker I don't believe that
the feds have any interest in the
individual user or a small group users I
don't believe they have any interest in
that at
all if you are like the gentleman um up
north that was growing mushrooms for
restaurant use and happened to have a
back room that he had did not fully
disclose uh and was producing relatively
large amounts of psilocybin mushrooms I
think the feds uh become interested in
that there are at this point many
communities that have
decriminalized uh COC cybin mushrooms uh
specific to no will effect that I'm
aware of and the feds have
asens
taken uh taken no notice other than to
uh put out press statements that they
they don't approve of it and it
shouldn't be done
um you know if you if I got caught if I
left here and I I got picked up by our
friends in the law enforcement and was
found to be in possession of say a
quarter of an ounce of psilocybin
mushrooms uh I doubt that I would be
brought up on federal charges I would be
brought up on state drug charges and I
would uh end up just north of here
um would be my would be my guess now if
I got pulled over and I had say you know
100 kilos of mushrooms in the back of a
van that that probably would get
escalated to a federal level I I guess
my question wasn't necessarily about the
prosecution as much as the impact for
example my own son he's 16 and I warn
him you know don't even experiment if
you intend because he wants to be a
lawyer intend on possibly working for
the federal government because you will
be given a polygraph um if you a job
where the security clearance and if you
admit to the use of for example a
psychelic you're probably going to be
automatically ruled out and that same
goes for law enforcement many things so
when we say okay
nobody not putting an age limit like 21
where people have a better chance of
understanding the impacts of their
decisions um that's what I was trying to
get your your feel for
that yeah I
so I want harm reduction and I want a
protect young people because they're the
ones that are most negatively impacted I
don't believe that we could get a bill
passed today so I I would not encourage
that that as an amendment at this
time again because of the
way we talk about psychedelics in drug
programs I don't believe anybody takes a
psychedelic for the first time lightly
it's it is it it is it is a decision
that most people think about for a long
time before they make the decision to do
that and to be quite
Frank the legal status with LSD s
assignment plays virtually no role no
role in making that decision because
typically firsttime users are going to
get a dose from a friend and and so
their their legal risk at that point is
incredibly low right I take possession I
ingest and then I'm then I'm done well
New Hampshire law enforcement certainly
has been more aggressive about um
internal possession charges for miners
uh and alcohol uh you would be much more
hard pressed that's that's an issue the
the con concern is real
I
understand your concern I I just don't
see where this bill would negatively
impact that thank you um representative
true thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my
question Bill deals with criminalization
uh The Possession and the use of soloc
cyan
mushrooms my question
is you feel that this also applies to
liquid solosy which I assume might be a
manuf
should psilocybin
chemical
so you feel this also applies to the
chemical itself of psilocybin which I
assume would be the liquid psilocybin or
is it just for the physical mushroom
that contains thank you for the question
so
psilocybin is the molecule that is
psychoactive within a mushroom there are
other compounds because micology is
quite
complex that also play a role and
influence the impact of the psilocybin
on the human
body this bill under my reading goes
directly to naturally occurring
psilocybin within uh fungi within
mushrooms this bill does not go to um
synthetically produce
psilocybin which typically would be a
would be crystallized as a salt it's a
it's a large molecule the reason the the
speaker probably is referencing liquid
psilocybin is because it's generally
dissolved in a carrier um either
distilled water uh sometimes an alcohol
solution um to make dosing easier the
the amount the physical amount that's
required is incredibly small and so to
be able to dose
synthetic
psilocybin reliably you have to dilute
it so that you can get that control this
bill I do not believe uh would cover
synthetic psilocybin nor do I believe
that uh liquid psilocybin synthetic
psilocybin is available um on the black
market to any any degree at all I I
believe that that is primarily being um
used in the studies that are are ongoing
at Cornell uh and
institutions uh where they're they're
probably choosing the the pure compound
as it's a little more controlled
although some of the studies are are
also using
mushrooms thank you thank you
representative thank you to the
committee for uh for taking my testimony
and the excellent questions and uh
please pass this Bill thank
you
thank there being uh no further speakers
on the matter we're going to go ahead
and close the public hearing on the
spell and I'm going to open the public
hearing on hb1
1215 an act relative to the definition
of a residual amount of a controlled
drug and representative bazaro is
recognized introduc
well thank you uh Mr chairman uh for the
record uh representative Al Bal theau
Rockin him County District five which is
London
Derry hb1 1215 I've got a call a day or
two days before our um submitting bills
from I'm sure you all remember
representative L blankenbecker uh she
was the attorney for um um hired by the
Hillsboro County uh John cof former
judge and County attorney but anyways
asked if myself uh or French Senator
French would submit this bill for them
because of the many issues they're
having in the court system in Manchester
tying up the courts on certain amount of
I don't know if it's marijuana or what
it is um I sent an email to judge cough
attorney Coughlin there and asked him to
have somebody here because Lyn Blake and
Becka uh got uh deployed so she is right
right now uh not with the county as
she's somewhere in another undisclosed
location doing her military job so this
bill um I really can't answer to it uh
on the legislation because uh somebody
who's not a lawyer and I you will have
somebody stepping up here that will be
speaking in support of it uh and I'm
hoping that with the duty experts in
this committee feel free to make an
amendments as needed because there may
be a couple of areas on drugs that need
to be added in here as um I mean as I
was talking with the chairman on like um
the fix to make sure that it's not
covered in this bill and um like I said
there will be somebody stepping up here
to speak and I'm not sure if anyone here
is here behind me from Hillsboro County
um attorney's office here so and that's
basically uh all I have the reason why
it's brought it
forward um representative troop thank
you Mr chair thank you for taking my
question I'm sorry I missed the
beginning statement you were submitting
this for who uh for the county attorney
for H Hillsboro County attorney uh John
Coughlin and representative Lyn
blankenbecker she's the one that sent me
the information and uh I got on the
phone with Senator French and he said to
me why don't you go ahead and file it we
didn't have time to get you know other
sponsors on there as I was sitting in
Florida and I said I'd be more than
happy to uh take care of it thank you
you're welcome Mr uh
representative uh go ahead represent
actually question of the chair do we
have other speakers on this we do okay
thank
you there is a duty expert that's coming
up who's a law professor and uh it's not
that often we agree on things but uh I'm
sure he'll make a difference he'll be up
next thank you representative
Bazar the chair
recognizes
um if I'm correct Professor
Sher did I get that right is it
Professor yes and commissioner H and
commissioner uh good morning everyone uh
my name is uh Buzz Sher uh I'm a newly
elected uh police commissioner in
Portsmouth uh as well as a law professor
at unh law I am uh speaking uh in my
individual capacity and my testimony and
opinions uh are not those of either the
Portsmouth police commission or UNH law
or the university as a whole um I'm in
uh support of uh HB excuse me HD1
1215 um uh for a couple of reasons and
then with as uh representative balesar
referred to with one SU question for the
committee um that um I'll get to uh one
uh I'm support in support of it for two
reasons one um the War on Drugs has not
been
successful it's been operating
for 50 years almost 50 years at this
point at least and it has become the
black hole of government money be it
State money or federal money and and we
just keep pouring money into it and the
problem is no better solved now than it
was when the War on Drugs first started
uh so uh I think uh I think it's an
expensive effort that is misguided in
the long run uh in terms of dealing with
the essential problem which is uh a
mental health issue it's a drug
addiction issue and uh you know counties
are spending money municipalities are
spending money states are spending money
the federal government is spending money
and it's just not getting better you
know the opioid crisis is the best
reflection of that in spite of all the
Draconian in some instances drug laws we
have in the in this state and in the
United States uh there was an opioid
crisis you know if the drug War on Drugs
was working we wouldn't have had the
opioid crisis
um so you know it's it's it's a black
hole for money uh and uh so I think it's
in the War on Drugs is ineffective it's
expensive and it's uh in the end it's
proven to be misguided the money is
better allocated to uh uh drug treatment
uh substance abuse uh issues uh and not
uh the prosecution uh I think
other uh Witnesses who will testify to
how uh how much money this bill would
save if we're not Prosecuting these
smaller amounts at the felony level um
which is what this bill in part
accomplishes and it also says you know
if you if uh the police find the residue
of a drug uh uh on a in a container or
on a pipe or something like like that
it's ju basically it's just not worth
the money uh to uh prosecute that case
and I would point out that the the real
impetus behind this bill is a county
attorney the hills Ro County
attorney uh my guess I haven't talked
with uh County attorney kogan but my
guess is he would say and I will talk to
him but he would say we just got to stop
wasting our money on these kind of
prosecutions um so I would suggest uh
and I will draft something and submit it
to several members of the committee I
would suggest that uh there may well it
may well make sense to make an exception
for fentanyl I think amounts of fentanyl
under one gram can still have a
devastating effect and so uh I think I
think there's relatively simple
language that can be drafted to carve
out fentanyl of less than one gram uh in
in the residual amount
definition with that uh I'm more than
willing to take
questions um I don't see any I'm going
to recognize myself for a question
um so this law it proposes to
change um The Possession of all
controlled substances over a
gram if I'm reading this right to a
class A misdemeanor
correct
so in other words if I were to be found
with a kilogram of cocaine would this
not
apply uh it would apply but if you're
found with a kilogram a kilo of cocaine
you would be prosecuted in the first
instance it's very very likely you would
be prosecuted by the US
attorney uh for a possession with intent
to sell at the federal level and even if
not which would be rare uh but even if
it wasn't prosecuted the federal level
uh you would be prosecuted with
possession with intent to sell you know
you can't make an argument that uh this
is uh that possession of a kilo of
cocaine is a simple possessory amount um
and you would without question be
prosecuted either in state or federal
court for possession with intent of sell
I would point out uh to the chair that
uh this committee is going to hear a
bill uh this afternoon HB
which overlaps with this bill it also
accomplishes reducing the Poss
possessory amount of a controlled drug
to a misdemeanor it has more more uh
Nuance or complication depending on
one's view uh has more Nuance or
complication in that it makes a second
possession of a small amount of a
controlled substance a felony at the
discretion of the judge so uh you know
and uh hb1
1232 um also deals with drug King it
abolishes mandatory sentencing for drug
kingpins on the theory I'm not going to
be here this afternoon so I'll just say
this now on the theory that drug p
Kingpin are virtually always prosecuted
at the federal level they're just never
prosecuted uh at uh at the state level
um so this is wasted
legislation uh uh that wasted bill that
not Bill wasted statute that's currently
in effect um it's not needed uh and uh
uh it can it's it's always handled in
the joint state federal task force it's
always handled at the federal level by
contrast uh the feds excuse the federal
government uh the federal government
rarely prosecut prosecutes possessory
amounts all right any any questions oh
go ahead representative Lane thank I ask
you put your law professor hat on answer
this question so again doesn't the
prosecutor already have the discretion
to reduce a misdemeanor down to a
violation is one question and then the
second question is in the definition of
misdemeanor here because it doesn't
specify A or B where an a would have
jail time A B has no jail time fine only
doesn't this just do the same thing it's
going to be a B misdemeanor and it's
going to be a
um again the prosecution has the choice
or the discretion to negotiate a lower a
lower fee or a lower sentence um two
answers I'm a law professor I gu two
answers um answer number one this uh
1215 specifically says a misdemeanor so
it doesn't give the prosecution just of
Mis not capital
a uh it says however a person shall be
guilty of a Class A misdemeanor if the
amount is the the last old section of uh
the proposed
legislation I I apologize I wasn't clear
I meant under current law it just says a
misdemeanor not a Class A misdemeanor
and that would be a by definition under
a penalty statute that would be a B
misdemeanor because it's not defined um
which has no jail time involved anyway
um I think it's noteworthy that uh the
county attorney for our largest county
wants this leg
uh he has dis discretion but what it
does is it CLS clogs up the system with
these small cases these small possession
cases and it involves uh a lot more work
for their office and I think as most on
this committee know the Hilo county
attorney's office and any other number
of County Attorney's Office are
overwhelmed with cases at this point uh
and uh that they can get rid of these at
the fr and uh in a circumstance where
they may well exercise that discretion
anyway uh is uh it's a positive thing
again uh understanding it's uh it's it's
a proposal effectively coming from the
hills Ro Atty attorney's office so yes
the answer is they have the discretion
but they just assume screen it out in a
more sum summary
fashion representative
Conley thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking the question can you
explain the significance of uh one gram
and why it's not seven grams or 43 grams
what is one gram and why is that the
number that was used in this bill one
gram captures uh uh very often it it
captures an amount that is uh has little
effect um uh number two uh one gram
captures a a possessor
a personal possession amount a personal
use amount it doesn't capture a drug
dealer of any sort even those lower tier
drug dealers who are you know selling
marijuana it doesn't uh it does it the
less than or one gr well less than one
gram captures an amount that is
essentially
possessive representative calling excuse
me personal possession thank you thank
you for that clarification so this is
essentially about personal use a
quantity that somebody might be uh
caught with
um is that um how is that typically
prosecuted are they are these plea deals
is somebody going to jail are these
being just tossed out because they don't
have the time could you provide some
context on that please yeah
um particularly there's an overlap here
with felonies first um a a a case that
uh uh a circumstance or a practice of
the superior court that uh tends to F
funnels all felonies to the county
attorney level possession of cocaine uh
less than a gram uh or a gr grammar
above put aside the large amounts of
cocaine is uh is in the first instance
prcu is a pony and Prosecuting Superior
Court so it's a tremendous burden on the
count attor offices uh and uh number one
number two you end up having a lot of
people 18 19
2021 acquiring felony convictions uh
when uh which will be their only
intersection with the criminal justice
system but it will have a profound
effect on their ability to get a student
loan their ability to get housing their
ability to get into schools um and uh it
it it too often because of the
overwhelming case load of County
attorneys in terms of drug cases this is
a felony just plead that the felony will
give you no a No Time sentence uh and
it's a uh it's a process that too often
results
in young people who are otherwise going
to be unengaged in the criminal justice
system acquiring a felony conviction
that
has legs throughout their
life representative Lang thank you sir
so again if I if I read the statue right
and again I'm gonna ask you for your
interpretation is this is going to apply
to all drugs drugs all control drugs and
we're talking about drugs like fentanyl
which less than the gram has the
likelihood of killing you how does that
play into this legislation uh that's
what I'm referring to when I refer to an
amendment that will help act for some
member of the committee that makes an
exception for
f representative
TR thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my
question uh I'm trying to sort out the
two different changes in in the bill uh
referring to the uh small amount less
than a gr I okay I understand what that
is uh you've got a marijuana pipe and
you've got some uh uh get what THC in
the
bottom and we're not going to like
bother people we're not going to clog
the courts with that I don't understand
the second part however a person should
be guilty of a Class A misdemeanor if
the amount of the controlled substance
is one gram or more
so personal possession amount of cocaine
I have no idea what that amount is but
depends on the um representative true is
there a question yes so
how if the how is that going to not clog
up the courts if it's still going to be
if it's going to be a Class A
misdemeanor or personal possession of
cocaine it will uh it will the casys
will go not to Superior Court because
it's not a felony it'll go to to uh
District
Court um and there's a lot more
flexibility the only good
case thank
you thank you for your
testimony at this time the chair
recognizes Lieutenant Bill
brigh good morning once again uh my name
is Lieutenant billb uh with the New
Hampshire State Police overseeing the
narcotics and investigations unit um my
testimony is one of uh information only
there's a lot of talk in here about uh
more or less than one gram and uh as was
noted uh with the O category of opioid
drugs that's uh an extremely dangerous
uh dose um anything um for fentanyl
specifically um we look at a a gram
could potentially be 10 fatal doses um
of Fentanyl and if you get into um car
fentanyl that's basically theze size of
a uh half the size of a grain of salt um
for heroin that would be the size of a
sesame seed just to put put things into
perspective for um for opioids and how
that would be affected by the bill as it
is written
here thank you for your testimony thank
you at this time the chair recognizes
David is it
rosin good morning thank you for um
recognizing Mr chairman members of the
committee so um I am one of the
directors of the state's public defender
program um as the chair in the the
committee know uh we represent the Lion
Share of the folks that um this bill
would would affect and I am um
testifying in support uh of the bill and
I'd like to make uh three points before
I hopefully take some questions uh first
the bill would reduce uh case loads and
workloads not only within our public
defender program but systemwide in terms
of the Criminal Justice System second it
would allow law enforcement to focus on
drugs is a criminal Enterprise rather
than a public health issue and third it
would allow the state to focus on uh
treatment options and the delivery of
services for what is often a public
health issue rather than a criminal
matter so first in terms of the
reduction in case loads and we heard
from representative baldasaro he
reported information from the Hillsboro
County Attorney's Office about their
case loads and I think that that has
been publicized I remember reading an
article in the union leader where the BB
County attorney himself was talking
about the overwhelming case load that
his office has um we are no different at
the New Hampshire public defender um I
can I'm going to give you some numbers
about New Hampshire Public Defender
cases because I think they're
interesting and instructive I think I
can safely say that this bill would not
only reduce case loads in the New
Hampshire public defender but it would
uh reduce case loads on contract
attorneys who take our overflow cases um
County attorneys as we've heard uh the
courts uh the police and the New
Hampshire State lab I think would all
see the impact of uh of this bill so I
looked at um our numbers for 2019 which
was our last normal year our last full
pre-pandemic year hard to believe um in
that year we opened up a total of
222 felonies that were possession of
fentanyl possession of
heroin possession of heroin or F drug
that I I think this committee knows has
become
quite prevalent in this state so that
was 2200 felonies that we opened in
2019 that was 28% or over one quarter of
all of the felony cases that we opened
and I looked at 2021 uh the numbers in
2021 were lower because 2021 was our
pandemic year still and everything was
slower but was still the same percentage
it was
27.8% of our case load so this is a
pretty consistent figure um that 28% of
our cases are simple possession of the
drugs that I've mentioned I also looked
at the numbers for the more serious drug
offenses and what I'm talking about
there is possession with intent to sell
for example the kilo of of cocaine
somebody with a kilo of cocaine would be
charged with possession with intent to
sell uh that cocaine and also sale of a
drug and sale of a drug would be treated
differently would not be touched by this
bill it's a more serious criminal
Enterprise so in uh 2019 we opened a
total of
194 uh possession within tent cases
dealing with those drugs that I
mentioned and we opened a total of 220
sale cases involving the drugs that I
mentioned so about 414 total cases
during that year were possession within
10 cases and sale cases about that
Universe of drugs so if you break that
down looking at the numbers we handle um
10 times more simple possession cases
than we do possession with intent cases
we handle 10 times more uh simple
possession cases than we do sale cases
uh we handle five times more simple
possession cases than we do the combined
possession with intent and sale cases
and if you look at a a felony attorney
in the New Hampshire public defender
let's say that um that man or that woman
that f attorney has 30 felonies on their
case load which is probably a pretty
reasonable number for someone to have
eight or nine of those cases at all
times would be the simple possession
cases so more than a quarter of that
person's cases so to look at it another
way again just talking about these
simple possession cases we figure the
average felony from start to finish
takes about 15 hours of attorney time to
resolve so if you add all that up that
means that in 2019 we spent 33,000 um
and again as has been referred to these
are
quties that are either residue or they
involve what is typically a user
quantity of of the drug and in terms of
how they are ultimately prosecuted in
response to one question they're taking
a long time to get through the system
and they are typically ultimately
prosecuted with a felony conviction with
little or no jail time and with little
or no treatment so you have to wonder
what all that time and effort is is
really going into to keep this a
felony so under this bill House Bill
1215 if it's adopted um public defenders
contract attorneys um the county
attorney's office and the Superior Court
are never going to see cases that are
under a gram which is a lot of cases a
lot of cases are residue or under one
gram typically um it would take a little
bit of time and a little bit study to
determine exactly how many cases would
be filtered out but maybe 25 to 50% of
the cases would be a gram or less the
police would issue citations for these
offenses um probably the police would
not have to go to court in many of these
cases the lab which also has talked
about a significant backlog and testing
drugs would not have to test the drugs
in these cases where they do now so the
other Cas misdemeanor as
has
it's been discussed by Professor sh they
resolve a lot more quickly typically an
attorney spends five instead of 15 hours
on a misdemeanor case from start to
finish they're just less complicated so
even if we get a thousand misdemeanors
per year that's 5,000 hours of attorney
time uh in our program as opposed to
33,000 hours of attorney time that we're
spending now now I assume though I don't
know um that um somebody looked at
Oregon when they proposed this
legislation because um Oregon has uh
legislation in place that is very
similar to this if not identical to this
legislation um according to an article
by the Pew Foundation uh before Oregon
adopted this measure there were 6,700
arrests for simple possession Statewide
and about 4,000 convictions for simple
possession afterward there were 1800
arrests and
364 uh convictions so there was a
significant reduction in the workload on
everybody involved in the criminal
justice system from the police all the
way we'd have to do some
stuff and see if that really happens
here um the legislature all of you are
well aware of the backlog in the
criminal justice system that in part
has been visited Upon Us by the pandemic
making cases much much harder to resolve
for everybody if we had something like
this even for a year to revisit it in a
year it would be worthwhile it would
have a significant impact in terms of
case load and
workload um second Point um drug crime
the Enterprise of drug uh criminal
activity um we are well familiar at this
point with the concept of addiction
being a medical cont concept being
substance use disorder being every bit
um as much of a a medical issue as
alcoholism or other things that we maybe
more familiar with before we even heard
of of fentel um if this bill is enacted
you are not sending a message that these
drugs are okay by any stretch you are
distinguishing between people who have
an addiction who have a user quantity of
the drug who have a medical issue and
people who are engaging in the
Enterprise of criminal activity for
example the person who's got uh the kilo
of cocaine the person who has drugs
packaged for sale or who is selling the
drugs so if this bill goes into effect
we still have a lot of laws state and
federal to combat the Enterprise of drug
activity we have the crime of possession
with intent to sell that I'd be glad to
talk about if people have any questions
we have the crime of sale we have the
crime of uh drug sale with death
resulting which obviously this would not
be affected by we have conspiracy laws
um that also apply if um it's a gram
even as small as a gram of fentanyl
there is still the possibility that that
drug is packaged for sale or that the
police have other intelligence that this
person who maybe only has a gram is
actually a dealer or is actually
engaging in a conspiracy so even if it's
a relatively small amount a gram or a
bit over a gram a person can still be
charged with sale of possession with a
10 but the Practical reality is that
when you're talking about a very low
quantity of a drug you generally have
somebody who is using it because they're
in the grips of an addiction also the
police obviously can still make an
arrest of a person if they are driving
either under the influence of one of
these drugs or if they are in active
withdrawal from one of these drugs the
law has recognized
that um again looking at Oregon based on
the articles that I've read Oregon has
not noted so far even though the
legislation is new they have not noted
so far a substantial increase in crime
drug rated crime or people just deciding
well now that this has been penalty's
been taken down why don't I just go out
and try some fentanyl they're not
discovering that that is is happening
and that's typically not the way that
someone just decides oh I'm just going
to go use some fental these are
typically people using the drug who are
sick and who need who need help and need
treatment so there is a decent chance
and while it would be more study there
is a decent chance this can be done
without a substantial increase in crime
or threat to Public Safety um and then
finally the focus on uh treatment in
Oregon um just as here a very
substantial substance use to sort our
population in that state just as we have
here and as here uh in Oregon they found
it very difficult to deliver effective
treatment the criminal justice system
just not was was just not the place to
deliver treatment for this this system
isn't doing it either I can tell you um
there is a drug court here but it's only
a very small sliver of the people that
enter the criminal justice system who
are eligible for drug court um most
other people are being recycled in the
system and are not being helped they're
being they're getting feling time
they're getting suspended time and
probation it's taking longer but they're
not getting help and this would allow U
the introduction of more funds into
resources for people who are afflicted
with um sub s order so I would um speak
in support of the bill I'd be glad to
take any questions if people
have representative
Roy uh thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question what impact do
you think that if through this were to
pass would there be on the existing
incarcerated population who are in
incarcerated for something that would
then no longer be um worthy of
incarceration do you see a a mass
movement of motions to have those cases
dismissed uh what do you see the impact
of that potentially being well there's a
couple questions there represented Roy
first of all I guess would be the the r
potential retroactive impact of this
bill and and as as I'm sure you know
most bills are not retroactive they're
they're perspective so the the
legislature would have control over that
there may be some people who might try
to make arguments that it applies IR
retroactively but those are generally
not successful so if that's a concern
that there would be a flood of people
coming in and saying well now it should
be a misdemeanor we experienced some of
this when the legislature would uh
changed the penalties for sexual assault
to a misdemeanor in some cases and
people were not successful at uh getting
retroactive application of that because
I don't believe it was the intent of the
legislature in terms of present numbers
there are a number of people who are
held pre-trial there are still a number
of people who are sentenced due to uh
possession related crimes simple
possession related crimes I do believe
that it would reduce the burden on the
county population the state prison there
are so many people up there who need the
focus program at the state prison the
waiting list is much much longer than
they can um than they can um afford it
would allow services to be delivered if
not as many people
to State Prison because of a simple
possession case if there were other
options in the community which as
wonderful a state as we are which we do
we do la the
Pres thank you
you we are we're running way behind
schedule chair now
recognize Ian Freeman
hello again just want to quickly speak
in favor of this bill I support harm
reduction uh people are not always
addicts when they get arrested for
possession of whatever substance we're
talking about it may simply be someone
who is able to use the drug responsibly
as many of us do with alcohol um and yet
they're being saddled with with felony
convictions and their lives are being
ruined um so that needs to change and
this bill does a good job of moving that
in the right direction my only quibbles
with it is that uh I would like to see
the amount raised as far as what is
considered a residual a residual
substance I don't think that would re
really be a big deal um because I don't
I really don't want to see people hit
with a Class A misdemeanor either um
just for a small possession so it would
be nice to see uh either the misdemeanor
reduced to just misdemeanor that way it
could be charged as a Class B if
necessary and uh raise the uh the amount
for residual amount that's all I have
thank
you thank you for your
testimony all right um there being no
more pin cards on this um we're going to
go ahead and close the
hearing on this
Bell and um
we're going to take a f minute
recess
e
Wonder
for
e
right
at this time we will now open the public
hearing on HB
1361 representative Roy the floor is
yours once you find the
bill
is this is this for representative Roy
to
complete friendly reminder to
representative Roy to complete the pin
card after your
testimony see if he's in support of his
own
Bill thank you Mr chairman I am here
presenting for the committee's
consideration House Bill 1361
establishing a penalty for any person
who transports control drugs into New
Hampshire with the intent to
distribute um as we are all aware the
vast majority if not all of the
controlled substances that are
contributing to our opioid problems and
other problems do not originate within
the borders of the State of New
Hampshire this alone um caus me to do
some research on how we could possibly
stem the tide of drugs coming into New
Hampshire and discourage the importation
of drugs so I looked to other states um
and I found that such uh conservative
Bastion as California have a similar
Drug law that makes it a felony to
import drugs into the state of
California um Texas there there were
roughly I think over a dozen that had
laws similar to this that made the
importation of drugs into the state a
separate and distinct crime that was
more
severe in introducing this law I believe
that it will
discourage um people from driving across
the border with distributable amounts of
drugs it makes their vehicle subject to
forfeiture that's going to make um
people that are letting other people use
their car or having them drive them in
their car
are um think twice about coming to the
state and bringing drugs into the state
it's a very simple bill um and uh that's
really it I I hope that you'll support
it and I'm open to
questions representative Balon you are
recognized thanks for taking my question
um I saw in the bill that you want to
carve out
um 2 ounces or less of cannabis or any
cannabis not exceeding the amount
permitted in RCA
126x that seems to be 2 ounces and I I
Googled it and I guess the limit in
Maine is two and a half and I I guess um
I'm just curious if is there a question
yes um I'm curious if
you know more than I do because I'm
concerned that someone might go to Maine
purchase something legally cross the
border not realizing that they're facing
a felony and I want to know if that's
been taken into consideration I only
Googled it quickly um I I most certainly
probably do not know more than you but I
can tell you um I based this what was
legal in the Hampshire I didn't consider
what others because if someone it's my
understanding that two o is the legal
limit in Hampshire so if somebody went
across the border and bought two and a
half ounces they'd be in violation of
the New Hampshire law as it was so I
didn't really consider what is legal in
other states just what it would be
illegal to possess in New Hampshire and
with the intent to distribute obviously
we' be exceeding that legal limit so I
didn't really consider what what may may
or may not have but it may be worthy of
looking into it
further thank
you
just an observation considering
representative Roy as a member of the
committee we could have this healthy
discussion in an executive
session but representative Newman I'll
recognize you for a
question quick question so what you what
you were just discussing in the last
paragraph
says p with an intent with an intent to
uh to sell or distri I guess it says
distribute somebody body that did have 3
ounces or two and a half ounces that
came in and it was not packaged that way
then they
would they wouldn't be penalized like it
that
corre no I believe that there's a a
specific um I don't know if it's in
statute or if it's in case law where
they've described what and what is not
intent to distribute in other words
several things may may make something uh
in intent in other words individually
packaged to resale uh simply the amount
itself especially with marijuana when
you start talking about the difference
between two and two and a half ounces I
don't think would qualify for the uh
intent to distribute uh threshold I was
I was hoping that the state police would
have stuck around we could have asked
that question but they're they're not
here um but it's a good question but I
believe that there's a separate standard
for what qualifies for intent to
distribute versus personal use um and
especially with regards to cannabis and
I specific specifically put cannabis in
here because not only is it um been
decriminalized but it's also legal for
medicinal purposes and I want to avoid
anyone who who's you know going to get
it for medicinal purposes being charged
with importation so I'd be open to any
and all uh amendments that could protect
people that are legally possessing it
for their medicinal
purposes thank you thank you
representative representative
representative Roy if I may ask
since we have some cannabis bills coming
up very soon it was just
mentioned specifically hb5 1598 which
are a co-sponsor of the bill with
me would allow for a 4 ounce possession
limit of canidates would it be any
interest in perhaps expressly excluding
cannabis from this this proposed bill I
I would not be opposed to uh to to
excluding cannabis altoe from the bill
cannabis um really isn't our main
problem as far as as compared to opiates
and um specifically Fentanyl and things
of this nature um so with the ever
shifting SS of the cannabis laws I I
would not be opposed to that
Amendment represent represent him true
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question um so what is the
present law for uh what is the present
law on intent to
distribute I don't have the statute in
front of me um but I know that it it
there are certain amounts and there's
certain case law that discusses um how
the how the pack the product is packaged
and things of that nature um and it
touches on several different statutes so
it would be it would be a lengthy
however I will will save the committee
um some time now and work I will
distribute to the entire committee um at
some point today the current statutes um
with regard to intent to distribut so
everyone has it at their
fingertips thank you representative
Roy
this time we will adjourn the the public
hearing on HB
next hearing is not noticed till 11:15
so we have some downtime representative
pantus it's great
to it's a great it's great to see you in
person yeah we're we're not we're not it
we're just sitting here there's nothing
open my microphone just on soone can
hear
me so we have 58 bills 57 it keeps
changing if there is an amendment to any
bill that anyone wants to do that we've
already heard I would always recommend
that remember get on that right away
because otherwise we'll be making
special appearances here just to exec
bills if we can get them
exec as you know if we have downtime
like right now we have downtime but it's
three bills all three with a potential
Amendment
so just throw that out there for future
reference
you don't have to raise your hand we're
not in any formal meeting you don't need
to be recognized by me oh okay it's a
free country all right
uh if you could just clarify because I
didn't want to waste time which we could
do later um on
12:15 which is the one that the county
the attorney wants to bring it is
increasing from a
class it's a misdemeanor to a class A
misdemeanor so it is increasing the
penalty is that
correct I thought it was making it was
redefining what a residual amount was
and making a residual amount a
violation that's correct no one has to
raise their hand we not in any form
correct I just don't want to step John
but anything
above um 1 oce or one gram right now is
a
misdemeanor and I think the Judge can go
either way where this specifies class
A if I may so again one of the reason
questions I was going to ask around that
discussion was UN you know the unusable
amount to conversation and being a a
misdemeanor it's a be misdemeanor which
should be held in District Court it
doesn't even have an option to go into
Superior Court if you're charged with
just residual amount be misdemeanor so
it doesn't even apply to the county
attorney because a B misdemeanor is
heard in District Court um it's only a
misdemeanor you have a potential a jail
time you can appeal and ask to go to um
Superior Court and have the case heard
in Superior Court um for those that
don't know I was a police prosecutor for
seven eight years so I I dealt with the
district court levels and probable cause
hearings in the district court to go to
felony court so um but the the big issue
is I mean the big part of that bill
isn't the definition of residual amount
the big big part of that bill is over
one gram being reduced to a a
misdemeanor because you're talking about
an ounce of coke is now going to be a
misdemeanor you're talking about six
grams of fentanyl more than enough to
kill multiple people could potentially
be defined as personal use and be a a
misdemeanor I I think we run into a
problem when we use that one generic
under under one gram for all drugs
you're scooping a whole lot of felonies
that probably should still be felonies
and making them all a misdemeanors so I
I I think that's part of the problem
with this bill it definitely needs an
amendment to clean it up and when you're
talk and using at that one gram
definition for every drug out to every
controlled substance there's some
concern that we are perhaps running a
course to the right to no act I do not I
and I was considering I could ask my
Democratic friends to leave the room but
I don't want to do
that he asked if if do we need to have a
notice our discussion I don't I mean
well you depending on your notice you're
always most most all of them are open to
work sessions and exec sessions at any
time so you could always open a work
session and have a discussion on it at
this time I will open a the chair will
open a work session on HB uh
2115 representative
Lang Lang I appreciate uh
thank you for pointing that out um
hopefully that we can open that
retroactive about five minutes
ago so so again that that on that bill
John that you're lowering the felony
level to an a misdemeanor on on the on
things that are currently drugs and then
uh so but again on the case of a
residual amount under one gram that is
already a district court so the argument
that it's residual amounts are clogging
up Superior Court is on its face wrong
because it's by definition in statute
that first sentence says un misdemeanor
and if you go our penalty section which
I had to look up a couple nights ago
anything that's not defined as an A or a
b and just says a misdemeanor doesn't
have the capital A in front of it is
automatically assumed to be a B
misdemeanor well I guess I I understand
the if it if it's not defined the when
they prosecute it it's their discretion
to make it an A or a B if it's an a my
understand they have the option to file
it in circuit court if they want to they
could go straight to Superior Court
that's so some of the I'm not sure what
they're doing in Hillsboro County if
they're going straight to Superior Court
they probably shouldn't be but they can
so one option benefit of having that is
that if it's an a a good deal to work
out is to reduce it to a b that's really
because then you don't you're not going
to serve any jail time so well so that's
an option it's it's always an option if
you charge it if it's as an if if it's
in the ha where it says misdemeanor you
start with an if I was Prosecuting I
would start with an a because the plea
is well Lou a jail time this is what
we'll offer you but this makes it a
violation so that it reduces all that to
the residual amounts because the
residual amount under current law it
says it's an unusual an unusable amount
on on a syringe or inside a syringe or
on the the needle of the syringe which
which an unusable amount I get that but
that's where the whole issue with one
gram came into play was what would make
is there any drugs that can be under a
under one gram but still be a usable
amount in it was fentanyl so so when I
was speaking the the buzz I said that's
the only issue really I see if you
support this policy you got to at least
emphasize that I was you shouldn't be
able to overdose on a residual amount so
if you possibly can overdose on the drug
if it's under one gram it really
shouldn't fall into this if if it's
because a residual amount I mean if you
had a a lot of addicts they'll put
their drugs inside of you know the
cellin of a pack of cigarettes well
there's going to be a residual mount in
there you can be charged I mean that's
not on a needle but I it's not really a
usable amount so really the goal is what
do we want to do with those type of
situations I'm surprised the police are
spending their time Prosecuting those
but that's that's that's their
disgression and so the other issue Mr
Jim if I may is that
the an element of the element of the
crime is you have to prove it's a
controlled drug so it's a violation a B
misdemeanor an a misdemeanor doesn't
solve the lab problem right they still
have to prove it's a control drug which
means it still has to go out to be
tested um if you're going to go forward
with it so again the lab argument
doesn't play by reducing the penalties
doesn't change the amount in the lab
other than you might get a plea deal
early before you submit it to the lab
you know uh other than that but so again
I some of the arguments around the
reductions and and it's it'll save the
backlog in the labs not true if I charge
a violation level offence for an
unusable amount and it send I send a
syringe or I send a plastic baggie or I
send the the spoon they cook their
heroin in um and it's an unusable amount
that will still be there I've been uh
notified by the clerk that we are only
noticed today for a public Hearing in
the um potential for an executive
session and it's not noticed for a
possession on a work session therefore I
would have to now close the work session
or actually you know what I'm I'm not
I'm not going to admit that it was a
work session but we are
gonna hopefully they have bad memories
but uh we'll we'll probably schedule a
work session on
this the proper
way hope you guys all
oh I'll like
me next time lock the
doors I will say you all my
co-conspirators though we're all going
down
together
the issue is if we are not in a caucus
and we're all talking about it it is a
right to no request because it has to be
a public
hearing I mean I feel that the doors are
open but I didn't write that that's law
in the books I mean the doors are
unlocked we're not like saying oh no
don't come in but legally speaking uh we
need to notice it so
I
I think representative pantelakis is
soliciting us to commit a crime
here you're soliciting us to commit
a no intent though I don't know the
answer to that but we want to air on the
side of
caution because he's hiding in the
ceiling I don't
know yeah
agreed so we're not we're not opening
any it's 11:15 so if anyone needs a
needs a break Now's the
Time
I
you we're not in we're just sitting here
there's no hearing
open you don't have to raise your
hand I could have and I just don't like
to admit I made a mistake in the noest
requirement in front of the entire
world
no
that's
I noticed that I'm not getting a
lunch lch youning
oning on the
dayss who do they
contact
e
there's
no there's
no
amount
e
spe
control
this time we will call the order call to
order the criminal justice Public Safety
Committee and we will open the public
hearing on HB
1296 this time the chair will recognize
representative Sylvia to introduce HB
1296 morning Mr chairman and committee
members uh for the record I am
representative Mike
Sylvia representing belnap 6 town of
Belmont uh I'm here to introduce HB
1296 a bill which will restore the
historically significant presumption of
innocence to the people of New Hampshire
and
Beyond this bill strikes two sentences
from RSA 318b colon 17b Roman 1 C which
has flipped the burden of proof from the
state onto the
defendant in the first case there is
established a presumption that property
found in
proximity to a controlled substance is
forfeitable beyond turning the
presumption of innocence on its head it
also allows an assumption that the
controlled substance is illegally
possessed while one could say a seizure
of a legally prescribed drug would be
quickly
overturned the fact is that in small
forter
cases uh the cost of an attorney would
quickly exceed the value of the property
seized in the second sentence the
language being struck shifts the burden
of proof from the state being required
to prove its case to instead Force the
defendant to prove his property has been
lawfully acquired and
held in the long history of Justice in
America it has been the duty of the
state to prove that a crime has been
committed and it is assumed that the
defendant is innocent unless the state
proves
otherwise while it is in fact a burden
for the prosecution to prove that the
law has been violated it is a burden
which has stood for centuries in America
and rightly so and with that I would uh
ask that you uh recommend all to pass on
this bill and i' be happy to take any
questions representative testman you
recognized thank
you thank you for Tak my question why
did you focus on what appears to be the
case of possession of PRS are
is this true in any other kind of
case I think this is probably unique
within our statutes that the presumption
has been uh flipped on its head where
the uh defendant has to prove that he is
innocent um I I don't know of any other
place in the law that uh such An
Occurrence
happens if I may inquire of a question
if you're in a situation
involving drug
trafficking wouldn't a large sum of
money be considered potentially evidence
of drug
trafficking and I I guess my point is I
understand the forfeiture of you know
person's property without being found
guilty of a crime yet but if if the
personal property or whether it's money
or what whatnot is evidence of the crime
isn't that necessary to for the state to
prosecute the case because if you're
found not guilty I presume you get your
money
back so indeed uh I I believe it is the
duty of the state to prove that money
and drugs are connected in some fashion
to just assume it that's fine but the
state should be uh carry the burden to
prove that that is in fact the
case if ask for a followup if a person
is charged charged with
a drug trafficking and they're found not
guilty wouldn't they their property or
money be returned to
them yes uh it would be but what what
this line does is turn the presumption
onto the defendant so instead of the
state having to prove its
case the defendant has to prove that he
was innocent or that his property was
innocent L
held and please corre correct me if I'm
wrong I just because I I always read the
law that if you are arrested you can
actually be convicted but still actually
get you the money back if you can rebut
the presumption that that money was not
used in the commission of a
crime I'm not going to argue with an
attorney because I know you're right but
in the way you said it but the the
presumption due to these two lines
becomes assumed and the defendant has
to uh make a case that his property was
legally held in all other aspects of law
it is the state that has to
prove uh with clear and convincing
evidence that that is that the the crime
has been
committed thank
you representative Lang thank you thank
you representative for taking my
question um so I I guess I I I'm not
sure of of your answer in in this in
what you said so if is do you think
after the state's proven the burden of
guilt in a drug um distribution charge
intent to sell charge that they then
have to and and you're convicted in
court do you think it's then the state's
responsibility to then again go back and
have to re litigate that to see if you
get your money back or do you think the
presumption of guilt the guilt that was
done in court proven in court is enough
to flip the argument make the defendant
prove that the money is not drug
related as I understand it and once
again I'm not an attorney what these two
lines do
is force the defendant to prove that he
is innocent this is contrary
to long-standing law for centuries in
the in this
country can I have a followup for that I
think I think there's an answer right
here you may follow up thank you so if
we left that sentence in there left that
whole sentence in there and just add it
after the controlled substance lying
upon a guilty
verdict would that clean up the statute
to a way that you would be comfortable
that shows that if you're guilty then if
you're found guilty in court of of of
the drug crime then you're going to lose
your your money but if you're you have
the right to AB but the state and try to
get it
back so once again um and I guess I
can't
really change my answer to communicate
what I'm I'm trying to say these these
words in this particular statute say
presumed to be
forfeitable and
then uh the claimant shall bear the
burden of rebutting
this presumption these flip normal law
on its head it
makes the assumption that the person is
guilty or the property is illegally held
uh I do have uh an attorney from uh The
Institute for justice who may be able to
uh put this into better words than I
apparently am
able representative
Newman
yeah I have some confusion over this
also um the sentence the sentence that
you and uh and simply uh are are turning
the uh presumption upon the
defendant go ahead with the
followup go ahead follow we just pointed
out that previous part of the bill there
ATK thank you um I'm going to recognize
myself for a quick question um I like to
when I look at statutes like this I'd
like to actually put a a real world um
scenario to it if I could so let's
assume the police execute a search
warrant they come into a house they find
um 50 Grands of
heroin prepackaged for sale and they
find
$15,000 in the in the house at the same
time it's not your intention that they
should not be able to seize that money
at that point is it you are correct that
the seizure is
absolutely valid and um giving myself a
followup your intent is that if they are
found not guilty the money should
automatically be returned to them they
should not have to go again and prove
that that money was theirs
legally I think the the what I'm trying
get at is
that the
prosecution should take the evidence
which has been collected by law
enforcement and prove that indeed the
money and the drugs are connected
without presuming that the defendant is
guilty it's always been innocent until
proven guilty and these lines flip that
on its head so I just I'm looking to
eliminate that presumption so that we
get back
to the presumption of
innocence thank
you representative
Conley thank you Mr chairman and thank
you representative what is the standard
that is used to determine in either case
is it a Beyond A Reasonable Doubt is it
a preponderance as to whether or not in
I think you understand the question yeah
so uh in Criminal trials it's uh clear
and convincing evidence to find guilt in
forfeitures it's preponderance of the
evidence so it's a lower standard and it
also once again is flipping the burden
onto the defendant or the property if
it's it's a in Rim
process thank you
representative
at this time the chair recognizes uh
Joshua
Albert and Mr Albert before you begin
testifying we're just going to shuffle
our seats down I'll slide down once with
us for one
moment
this
you may begin thank you chairman and
thank you to the committee for allowing
me to testify here before you today my
name name is Joshua Albert I'm a
detective Lieutenant with the Nashville
New Hampshire Police Department I have
been in law enforcement for over 20
years and specifically of that 20 years
around eight has been uh directly
involved in uh investigating and
enforcing narcotics
violations I am here to testify an
opposition of House Bill 1296 and I was
asked to testify in opposition on behalf
of the New Hampshire Association of the
chiefs of police
the focus on any Bill and this one in
particular should be how to legally and
effectively use the proceeds of
forfeited monies or property from drug
traffickers in constructive ways
Charities treatments drug investigations
Law Enforcement Training uh the rising
cost of equipment that allows us to
solve other
crimes specifically towards some of the
Chang es listed in the statute relying
on the word knowingly which remains and
removing the word proximity or
presumed while I realize the burden to
shift uh the burden of proof to the
state
however drug
traffickers are smart they're clever and
they are constantly adapting to the ways
that we enforce the
laws my fear
in removing words like proximity or
presumed is that with a simple one or
two levels of
insulation it
allows them to retain their money and
law enforcement to not forfeit
it I think the
focus should never be to help the
Distributors of poison protect their
profits
however allow law enforcement to use
those for more effective uh
Endeavors I'd like to give you one
example uh that we have recently seen in
which drug trafficking organizations are
utilizing pill presses to make uh drugs
like opioids and amphetamines look like
legitimate prescription
drugs so to use an example that was uh
mentioned earlier instead of finding 50
grams of an opiod or fentanyl
uh we find a cache of pills which to the
untrained eye and even on a simple
search of drugs.com would look like a
prescription drug
however that person doesn't obtain a
prescription they don't have a
prescription and a stack of money right
next to it or even in the other room for
that matter if we're talking about
proximity I would like you to find this
bill and expedient to legislate
due to the
fact
that law enforcement in general in
regards to forfeiture already carries a
high standard of meeting a certain Nexus
of connecting money drugs and other
property used in drug
trafficking be happy to take any
questions that you have at this
time I representative Roy
thank you Mr
chairman um thank you for taking my
question so with the scenario you just
gave pill press the the ingredients to
make the
pills drugs in the other room in a
safe in in making in getting there in
the first place would you not have
already applied for and obtained a
search warrant and perhaps done a
controlled buy out of there several
times would the the money from your
control buy where you mark the serial
numbers co-mingled with that stash of
drugs found in the safe not imply that
the entire amount of drugs were used as
or were fruit of a crime as it were as
it stands right now if we can locate
co-mingled funds then we would in effect
seize the entirety of the money thank
you representative
Conley thank you Mr chair chairman thank
you sir did I just hear correctly that
you would seize potentially illegal
funds as well as funds that may have
been uh profits from a legitimate job if
they're in the same place that is
correct you recognize for a followup
thank you and this is a question I
intended to ask but it's along the same
lines if you're confident in your case
and you're confident that somebody is in
fact Distributing these poisons what
would be the harm in a hearing to prove
that before one's property is
seized so those hearings typically
already take place uh depending on what
level of of forfeiture is going on the I
think the ask to shift the burden of
proof is from a law enforcement
perspective when that case is complete
and it is for fored to the County
attorneys for prosecution we feel that
we have met the Nexus to connect that
money and those crimes together I
think what I would don't want to see is
by a defendant simply saying nothing
or giving a any reason uh I have
recently received an inheritance and
that's how I received this money there's
going to be some type of paper trail
there that if those monies were obtained
legally that they would be returned
however currently if they cannot show if
the defendant cannot show that the money
was obtained
legally then it is presumed that that
money is
forfeitable thank
you representative Roy uh thank you for
one more question um um on the search
warrant it specifically would say what
you you shall seize it does it does it
say you may seize the fruits of a crime
or does it say you shall seize so a uh
search warrant particularly in drug
investigations usually comes with uh an
addendum that drug
investig as I've said I've been involved
in
Narcotics investigations for a long time
and what we have found in search
warrants when we're receiving them back
is that uh certain language will be
struck if it is not relevant by the
judge before returning that search
warrant of course if we enter our
property legally on the authority of the
search warrant and for example find a
gun that we did not know was there but
we believe was also used as part of this
crime we would stop the search amend the
search warrant and once it was signed
signed off then we would collect that as
evidence
so in regards to specific monies we are
always if we have controlled buys into
the location money would be something
that we would look
for representative Ro recognize for
followup I guess what I'm I'm asking is
do you have the discretion once you have
a search warrant a search warrant is
kind of like an order um from the court
to go conduct a search and seizure do
you have the discretion to to find drugs
then see money and say well I'm I'm not
going to take the money does the search
war and not direct you to confiscate
that as a fruit of a
crime so I've always been a doer and uh
this isn't really my realm of expertise
sitting in front of you but uh I'd like
to give you a situation and and that I
think better explains um we enter an
apartment on a search warrant where a
couple lives the target of the
investigation is the male that lives
there uh and we have nothing in the
investigation that would show that the
female is in any way
connected
the female has a purse on
her
has money in it that she claims to be
from a legitimate job and if we've done
our due diligence we know she works at
that job we would not arbitrarily sees
her money but now that being
said if among the search she had
co-mingled funds then it would suggest
to us that she was more involved than we
were led to
believe and in that case we would seize
the money because of the coinkle funds I
hope that answers your
question if I may may ask a question
please in a in a particularly a drug
case where someone is arrested and
suppos that there was uh money seized
what happens to that money if the cour
were to find that defendant not
guilty the money would be
returned and
we've so when we seize money uh that
money is is held in a separate account
and the forfeiture process itself goes
through the Attorney General's office
there is as I understand a a separate
RSA that allows County attorneys to to
have money forfeited as part of a plea
agreement um but we rarely do that in my
experience thank
you representative
Muse yes thank you for taking my
question um one of the things I'm
curious about is the potential impact of
the passage of this bill uh on police
budgets especially in larger cities uh
and something I'm not quite sure of is
what percentage of an operating budget
or other uh parts of the budget that are
used to fund uh uh uh either equipment
or other salaries or other critical
processes uh would actually uh go away
with this
bill so I I'll will speak from the
Nashville Police Department's
perspective uh my
division other than officers or
detective salaries um or gas is
100% funded through forfeiture
so the elimination of funds would
obviously bring with it a certain
detriment to the our abilities to
enforce narcotics violations I have
about uh at any time 15 to 20 officers
or detectives working for me and in
nashu give our take but it costs roughly
$100,000 a year to to run our division
um last year was a little bit of
a different it was quite more expensive
because we needed to do some things um
but I think and if you could bear with
me for just one
moment I think it's important to note
that the forer money
itself is not only used for drug
investigations
um it's it's used for equipment it's
used for computers it's used for things
uh that and really I have quite a a
number of things that uh that that money
is used for and so I think that the
impact would go far beyond any narcotics
enforcement representative Klein
Knight I'll just project um how much how
much of your budget is from
forfeiture
money the the police department's budget
in general yes
so forfeiture is held
and it can be used for law enforcement
purposes but it cannot be used to to
maintain a budget the the annual budget
of the police department that's done
through the city of
Nashua you recognize for a followup I'm
I'm sorry I'll take another stab at this
um do you know how much police funds you
get roughly about if it changes every
year from last year how much you
specifically receive for your department
based off of forfeit your
money so on the types of Investigations
that are
compl completed uh and from year to year
that that number fluctuates
by upwards of even
$100,000 representative
Balden thank you for taking my question
um I uh was just curious if you can't
account like anticipate the
amount how do you plan the use of it and
how is it factored into you know setting
the budget I guess it's just um like if
I was setting my budget and I knew I
might get some money but not sure how
much I don't think I could make plans
for how to use it so how does that work
and how does that fold into the idea
that that the result of passing this
legislation would be a budget
cut thank you so I guess to answer your
question I I wouldn't I wouldn't
necessarily say it's a budget cut uh
because I view the budget as something
that the city issues but our operating
expenses come from Fort fure within my
division the Narcotics Division
specifically
and in every year that I've been there
we have been able to maintain
um maintain our
numbers that we continue to
operate I think like anything else if
all of a sudden
uh a tree fell on my house I would have
to find the money from somewhere and
maybe I wouldn't go on vacation that
year I I guess that would be an example
so on Lower years we are paying more
attention to how much money we are
spending for drug investigations or
money that we give out to for their
computers or their
um memberships to the you know their
lawn investigative
tools
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
answering my question I'm looking at
this paragraph paragraph C is only
pertaining to uh currency coins
Securities and it basically talks about
two different kinds any that
are uh used intended to use for rec
recruitment manufacturer compounding
processing etc etc and the next has it
says all monies coins currencies Neal
instruments and securities found in
proximity now couldn't we make the
argument that any Securities found in
proximity were part of the
Enterprise and does it is it is that
sentence even
necessary I think that that sentence is
necessary because of the word
proximity and and in parts of my
original when I originally started
relying on the
knowingly and removing the word
proximity I I worry that we are allowing
potential
defendants uh avenues that onsite they
can say that those are legitimate funds
and even if they are found in proximity
to the drugs and it takes a tool away
from law enforcement
whereas if down the road those funds are
in fact proved to be legitimate they get
returned but if that defendant does not
have an explanation for where that
funding came from there is no paper
trail or we've done our due diligence
proving comingled funds money money
used during the investigation we show
that based on the preponderance of the
evidence that it was in fact drug
related and these things I think
are at times very easy to show someone
with no job no source of income no means
of of obtaining any money and yet they
have large sums of
it representative board you recognize
for a followup thank you so um it's it's
unclear that it's necessary but we'll
grant you that look at the last
sentences CL of the property will bear
the burden of reol and presumption so
you it appears to me that if this
sentence is not there then they claim it
uh can't necessarily get their property
back in that
paragraph and what's the question to
that sir I I'm I'm asking if
that's a good conclusion or
not so I think the the the sticking
point on the bill seems to be the the
burden of proof and where where shall
that
lie and from my standpoint and and
speaking on law enforcement
standpoint I think that in order for us
to seize the money we've already had to
show quite the Nexus to a drug
investigation so before we would even
seize it we we know it exists therefore
we are making that representation that
that this money is drug related it is
seized and if that defendant wants to
show that it is not drug proceeds then
let them do that all right thank
you representative
Newman
let me repeat what I said because my mic
was not on this is in reference to your
last sentence about where where you
there's been an investigation and there
is an ex exis between whatever the
situation is and
and the
forfeiture
and but but then the offend the
defendant in a case where he's been uted
by the state has to prove that the state
is wrong and like this previous
testimony said representative Newman is
there a
question one more sence previous I'm
talking about the testimony testimony
previously said
that that that this is the only place
that they see does is does
the I don't believe that the defendant
should have to prove it and do You'
agree with that I guess that's the best
way
well being in opposition of the pill the
bill I do believe that the defendant
should have to prove it because I
believe law
enforcement by seizing the money they
feel they've met their burden of showing
that there is a Nexus and that the the
proceeds were illegally
obtained thank you very
much thank you thank you for your
testimony and for taking our
questions
this time the chair is
recognizing Dennis and do I apolog I
can't read the last name but Dennis from
Pittsfield my name is Dennis Corgan
thank you I'm representing myself I'm a
resident of New Hampshire and um I've
worked on asset for forfeiture
legislation for six or seven years uh
this this legislation has um been in
place since I think
2011 and um it's um required some
modifications as time's gone on and this
is what this bill is is um is meant to
do let me just say that I think there's
a uh potential confusion in how these um
cases arise it it's not always the case
that there is a a warrant that's issued
or um a person who's found guilty uh at
all often um there's really two separate
tracks that the investigation proceeds
along one to prove that a person is
innocent or guilty and secondarily to
prove that the property involved is
innocent to guilty this could be money
it could
be houses computers cars and these are
um often seized um and
then later on the um the prosecutor will
will show that they are uh or not that
they are uh forfeitable
so the property can be a judged to be
guilty in independent of whether anyone
is is found guilty of a
crime um one other point I'd just like
to make quickly is that uh we've been
hearing about how if a mistake is made
and the money has been forfeited
incorrectly that the claimant can um can
get the money back if if it's if it's
his the problem with that argument is
that many many of these forfeitures of
money in particular are for relatively
small
amounts uh on the order of $1,000 and
when the uh claimants consider the
advisability of seeking to to get that
money back they've got to recognize that
they're going to have legal uh costs to
to take into account to make it
questionable as to whether it's
worthwhile on a net basis for them to
apply for that money
back those are the two main uh comments
I'd like to make at this point thank
you if I could ask a question
please so it was it your testimony that
there are circumstances where a
person defendant goes to trial is found
not guilty but they don't have their
money that was se's Return to them I'm
more thinking of the situation of a
roadside stop where there is no um
warrant issued where the where money is
seized and that's the end of the um of
the
process and if I may ask you follow so
you're talking about circumstance where
the money was seized but the person was
never formally charged with the correct
correct
right and if I me ask this one other
followup would there
be do you have any opinion on the idea
if there was any language added in a
potential amendment that if the if an
individual is found not guilty and not
prosecuted that any money sees would be
returned I'm not sure if I understand
the question sorry what I was asking is
if a per if if there was language added
to the to the law that if a person is
found not guilty or not ever charged
with any crime any money seeds would be
returned I think that'd be a great
Improvement absolutely
right thank you thank you representative
Klein
Knight thank you chair thanks for taking
my question um I have one in a
followup in your years of expertise how
often do you uh estimate that
roadside um confiscation of money
happens
it's difficult to know um certainly in
other
jurisdictions we see this happening
regularly but I can't give you numbers
or evidence about the particulars of New
Hampshire
situations and chair can I ask a
followup you
recognize would you suggest the use of
body warn cameras on police officers
would crack down on activities such as
that yeah I think that would be a a
reasonable
idea representative panel loock is
your are you saying that police officer
stopped somebody on the side of the road
and they take their money that it's they
they don't give it back is that what
you're
saying well yes they that is what I'm
saying because they need to make an
application to to get the money back and
I'm saying if it's a small amount often
it's not an economic uh idea to to work
that way the claimant may decide to just
let go of any claim on on that money
because they are not going to net back
very much after they've paid a lawyer to
to help them in
that thank
you any further
questions thank you for your
testimony um the chair recognizes uh Dan
Maguire The Honorable
D thank you very much Mr chairman and
members of the committee for the record
my name is Dan Maguire and I'm from
Epsom I was a state representative when
we started um reforming this area of New
Hampshire law maybe eight years ago or
so and um I think first of all there's
been a number of questions about um
amounts of money and and so on the next
bill you're going to hear is about
reporting and so the people that will
testify on that have the current set of
reports and so they can answer questions
about how much does nasua uh forfeit and
and so on things like that so so I would
suggest on the next bill you ask Reas
those questions this particular bill is
is fairly simple and it's it's just
about these two removing these two
sentences from New Hampshire law and
this is consistent with the way we've
been improving New Hampshire law on
forfeiture over the years in general
what we've done is switch it from a
system where there is what's called
civil
forfeiture um which just means that
there's effectively a a case against
forfeited property that's a civil case
it it doesn't require um it has a lower
burden of proof um it only requires uh
preponderance of the evidence not not um
um proof Beyond A Reasonable Doubt um
and it it because it's only a civil case
then um Indigent defendants are not
granted an attorney uh to to help defend
themselves and so on and and our and
what we've done over the years is switch
over to criminal uh forfeiture which
means number one if property is going to
be forfeited under New Hampshire law
then um you must have a criminal
conviction of the person for an
underlying crime first and then
forfeiture of of property used um in
those cases can be forfeited right so
you can't simply forfeit money without
also having a criminal conviction so
this particular Bill simply says um it
goes along with that by saying if you're
going to Forfeit something you you have
to prove um like in a criminal case that
that this thing was um used for the
crime right that's what the the words
traceable there too means in the in the
previous sentence so whereas current law
the things that are being crossed out
here is sort of the opposite it's kind
of like guilty until proven innocent
right it says that the presumption is
you prove to me that that this uh prop
was not used for this for this crime
right I mean I I have in my pocket here
I don't know
$200 um if if this was seized how do I
prove that I didn't get this from
selling drugs right I mean I I know that
I took it out of the ATM but you know
that could have been other money right I
mean how do you prove it so so really
it's the burden of proof should be on
the prosecutor to prove that this prop
this car was used to sell drugs this
this uh money came as the result of
drugs and so on that's that's the normal
sort of thing right so so um in general
that's what we've been doing with New
Hampshire law is we're saying if you're
going to be punished by having your
property
taken um it the burden of proof should
be on the prosecutor to prove that you
committed the
crime thank you Mr
chair representative Burt thank you
thank you Mr chairman and thank you uh
for your
testimony why in your opinion would the
police be so against this when it really
is the right thing to do is you know if
I have cash which I do occasionally and
I get it seized
um how do I prove where that cash came
from and I don't do drugs well yes thank
you for the question representative just
in general the current system allows uh
police even under New Hampshire law I
mean both the thing is there's
forfeiture under federal law and under
New Hampshire law and that's the subject
of another bill that's over in judiciary
at the moment but um but the in general
the there are incentives built into the
law um for for forfeiture to take place
because the results of forfeiture are
then um a significant part of them are
given to police departments and they're
allowed to spend that money um sort of
off Budget on things that they decide
that they want to spend on that have not
necessarily gone through the budget
process so it's it that's the
incentives thank you uh I'm going to
recognize myself for a question um so
when we lay out a crime in the
legislature we we have to or at least we
should put the the elements of that
crime um for the police to
prove so in in kind of culling this
money away from the the crime of the of
the possession with intent and saying
okay now police you've proved that I
sell drugs now you have to prove the
money you found was also um related to
those drug sales um how would the police
go about doing that if and unless they
happen to be lucky enough to have some
co-mingled funds in there from a
controlled buy how could law enforcement
proved that that money was in fact a
fruit of the crime and it should be
subject to Forfeit yes thank you for the
question representative um my
understanding is they can uh do
Discovery right like in any criminal
trial you can you can go and um get
people's
um um wage uh Records right you can you
can um you can uh if they run a business
business get the business records things
like that and they can they can show
that through those records that there's
more money here than than should be
there from um from legitimate means
right so I mean obviously the easiest
way is if um they're recording drug buys
they did drug buys all that sort of
stuff but even absent that um through
normal criminal procedures you can and
um you can investigate right and you can
you can get records and and show things
that way and I'm going to just followup
and what would the threshold be I mean
the the to to convict someone of the
drug dealing crime has to be Beyond A
Reasonable Doubt what would the
threshold be to prove that the drugs
were in fact related to the to the to
the yeah this about Cas yeah the cash
were was related to the underlying
offense same thing so the police would
have to prove Beyond reasonable doubt
that that money that they seized at the
same time as They seized the drugs was
in fact ill gotten through the drug
trade I think that's true thank you any
further questions uh yes representative
new I'll get used to the m in a minute
here my understanding as I read this and
I want to sit but I'd like you to let me
know if I'm correct or not it says that
these monies that are connected to a
phel felonius violation of of this
chapter so does that raise the bar of
the amount of money that's required to
above, is that I think that's would sure
though I'm I'm sorry but I don't
see see in
line it's the current law not the part
that's signed out current law oh I see I
heard saying control drug and fonus
violation of this chapter and all
proceeds yeah so thank you for the
question representative but I I think
we're starting to get into more detail I
myself am not an attorney and so I I
don't think I can answer answer that um
I see the word any monies at the top of
this sentence so I think that's any
amount and and one other thing that I do
know is sometimes amounts that are
seized and you'll hear that next with
the reporting section are small
amounts thank
you no further questions uh thank you
for your testimony thank you Mr
chairman and the chair recognizes Lee
McGrath Mr chairman members of the
committee thank you for the opportunity
to testify in support of this very very
modest piece of legislation uh my name
is Lee McGrath I'm the senior
legislative Council for a public
interest law firm called The Institute
for for justice uh I have it is a joy to
be back here in conquered and talking
about simplifying New Hampshire's uh
processes what I'd like to do today is
to
demystify some of the some of the
Dynamics that are in play here and show
just how simple and modest this change
uh change
is to a legislator's question earlier
I'll just jump to the numbers
approximately 300 Only
$300,000 a year is forfeited new in New
Hampshire and goes into the drug
forfeiture fund so we are talking about
a very small amount of money relative to
the large budgets that cities like
nashille and other New Hampshire cities
have for the important work of of law
law en
enforcement
but what the best way to think about
this bill is to think about process and
think about what it doesn't do what this
bill does not do is change at all
seizures seizure is the work of police
officers and sheriffs and
detectives it is the taking of property
seizure is the possession of property
you need law enforcement needs to meet a
very modest gold of goal but still a
standard of probable cause as the
chairman as the chairman
knows nothing in this bill deals with
seizure doesn't change anything about
probable cause doesn't change the work
of police officers and sheriffs and
detectives the next step is Criminal
conviction nothing in this bill changes
what happens in Criminal Court as it
relates to to convicting a person of a
crime the third
step is civil
forfeiture and in this step this bill
changes something
modestly it
changes who has the burden to prove to
provide evidence that currency and
instruments are related to the fruit of
crime are the fruit fruit of crime it is
a legitimate function of the State of
New Hampshire to confiscate the fruit of
crime in a world in which a suspect has
been convicted the next question is who
proves who has the who has the 51%
obligation of preponderance of the
evidence to prove that in fact that
currency was the fruit of
crime in this narrow narrow narrow
narrow
question this bill changes from 49 to 51
to 51 to 49 it changes the burden of
proof from the property owner who has
been convicted already from the property
owner to the the prose prosecutor to
prove in fact that that money was the
fruit of of the crime
now how does that happen today to to
make it even simpler Mr chairman and I'm
sure you your experience you you know
this exactly how does this happen in
today's world the property owner must
produce he must produce the bank
statements the pay
stubs evidence that there was a
legitimate source of that $600 or that
$2,000
in a in tomorrow's World in which you
pass that the prosecutor has to file
Discovery and and get those same
documents from the property owner
because the prosecutor needs those
documents needs criminal Discovery to
carry the new post Sylvia burden of of
of Pro proof so in reality it's this
this is a very you can see I hope this
is a very modest bill as to who does the
work F initially in today's law the
property owner provides the work
initially post enactment this bill
requires criminal
Discovery as the first
step in many you Mr chairman members I
hope that's helpful and I'm happy to
answer your questions as to the modesty
of this bill and how it is principally
driven by the author's conviction of
Burden that in our country the burden
whether it's on the pro whether it's on
the defendant or on the property in
Civil Court the burden should be on the
government
representative
Bert thank you Mr chairman and thank you
uh Mr graph for coming up here it's
always a pleasure seeing you
U I tried to look it up I can't find it
on Google there's a case that
was you know I just don't know when it
was it could be four or five years ago
it could be 10 years ago as time
flies a gentleman I believe came out of
Maine
entered New Hampshire he had like
$110,000 if I remember the case right
and all of a sudden the police pull him
over see the cash and They seized
it I occasionally will travel with some
cash what would I have to do if I got
stopped and the police saw the cash and
seized it and said you know I don't know
what they would say would they have to
say that it's drugs or or or how would I
ever prove where that cash came from uh
Mr chairman representative bird this is
a good question because it highlights
the difference between what this bill
doesn't change and what it does
change every the hypothetical or the
example that you that you gave is no
different under this bill than current
law the police can seize that 10,000
they can seize your
cash in today
tomorrow because they must have probable
cause a modest standard they must they
must see that there's some residual
drugs in the car they must there must be
a smell of
marijana they must have a dog that
triggers something that is all un
unchanged you go to trial in New
Hampshire you go to Criminal Court in
New Hampshire and you get convicted then
the f phase three is what happens to
that cash in civil court so in civil
court this is where today you have the
burden of showing receipts and Bank
deposits and pay stubs and things like
like like that in a post syvia world the
prosecutor has to initiate a criminal
Discovery now that Discovery can re can
include in uh interrogatories it can
questions it can include requests for
Doc and if you don't produce
that you have you have made the work the
burden of the prosecutor heck of a lot
easier he can walk into court and he can
say Mr Mr berd has no evidence to show
that this was a legitimate source of
money and besides that we've just
convicted him in criminal court for this
crime of possession with the intent to
distribute thank
you any further
questions uh representative
Newman have my mic
on um I'm GL to just repeat a question
that I had earlier for another witness
that I hope I'll say
better how does the amount CES relate to
the the term
colonious Val violation as it's stated
in line five of the
law where it says that it must be a
colonious violation of this
chapter so we're not Mr chairman
representative Newman once again this
has nothing to do with
seizure all the police officer all the
def detective needs is probable probable
cause what this has to do with is
forfeiture after a conviction so in new
New
Hampshire the money must be
tied to a a conviction in a
felony and this chapter is referring to
a felony conviction should that
conviction happen then this we go back
into civil court
and the question becomes becomes who's
got who's got to show who's got to
produce who produces evidence
first is that helpful just follow yes um
that is helpful and this is the current
law says
that my concern is how does that relate
to does it make a difference between a a
small amount like $600 or up to, doll
and amounts above that is there a
problem with that that this doesn't
cover because of the way the current law
is
written Mr chairman representative
Newman in principle in principle this
law treats 600 six $600 the same as it
treats
600,000 dollars so there's no change in
that now I overheard Mr Corgan talk a
little bit about the burdens of what
happens when when you the the economics
of engaging in all this process so for
example we know that it we don't have
this number for New Hampshire but we
know in Connecticut that the median
forfeiture is
$665 we know in Maine it's
$1,700 we know in my state of Minnesota
it's
$57 in Nationwide it's
$1,300 is the median forfeit and so Mr
corgan's testimony is not about burden
shifting his testimony was more about
the pragmatic effects of all of this
civil
litigation on relatively small amounts
of for for
forfeiture thank you very
much
if I may I'm going to indulge myself
with a question
um so we know when we we leave vagaries
in the law we what we open ourselves to
is judicial um judicial writing of a law
if you can so by taking this
away how I understand the burden would
um preponderance of the evidence
51% H how would the state then prove for
example that a large amount of money
that was seized in conjunction with a
drug forfeiture I mean a drug seizure
case was actually uh the fruit of a
crime barwing um what I brought up
earlier some some Co mingled marked
money or something like that how would
they meet their their burden Mr chairman
that's an excellent question and let me
just preference it by one small observ
observation that remember that the that
the median amount of currency for it is
is
$1,300 so now let's move to your
hypothetical the very the a common
concern which is a large not the 1,300
but the 130 thou thou
th000 the prosecutor will first have to
convict that person in Criminal Court he
will do a heck of a lot of work to
achieve that con con con
conviction
then what EV did the property did the
convicted person produce any evidence
that in fact there was a legitimate
source of this money in addition to the
type of drug control buys that you spoke
of and numbered bills and things things
like like that so in essence showing the
modesty of this reform Mr
chairman after
receiving Discovery the discovery qu
request the property owner really does
in effect have
to prove a legitimate source of this
money through the
discovery Pro
process so a defendant could not simply
say
the burden's now on you state I'm not
answering um it's my money and that's
all I have to say about it correct Mr
chairman a good prosecutor would say uh
uh would ask uh show us your W2 do you
have a
W2 I'd like to introduce it into I I'm
sure uh your defense attorney would like
to introduce it into e EV evidence your
honor there's no evidence
here and and since we've shifted that
burden away
we would no longer in other words he
wouldn't be able to just clam up and say
I'm not saying anything you prove it
now Mr
chairman all right let me take you into
the weeds let's go okay we're in Civil
Court taking the fifth amendment in
civil court is different from taking the
fifth amendment in Criminal Court in
France in Civil Court the tri a fact can
infer something negative so if the if
the def property owner after being
convicted in Criminal Court finds
himself on trial in civil court and he
refuses to answer or even takes the
marital privilege refuses to a answer
that can be inferred against
him I apologize for the weeds Mr
chairman
thank you um there be no further
questions thank you for your testimony
Mr chairman if I could just sure if you
would indulge me for just just um 11
seconds more uh my search of State
statues reveals that New Hampshire is
one of six other states that currently
has this burden on the pro property o on
the property owner in this in civil
litigation it is you are in a a minority
minority of
States dly noted thank you oh what we
have one more last minute question
representative true thank you Mr chair
thank you for than you my question and I
think I just like I I don't understand
this is my first term in the criminal
justice right now the burden of proof is
on the person it
is this law will change it so that the
prosecutor has Discovery I'm not sure
what Discovery is but the prosecutor
will now ask in Civil Court the person
to prove his innocence and if the person
doesn't I mean so the guy still has to
prove his innocency
yes Mr chairman representative
true despite a lack of experience in the
criminal in this this committee you've
nailed it th this is exactly if it ever
did get to
trial
the prosecutor would would would uh
would examine the pro property owner the
person who has been convicted and he
would say I I sent you criminal
Discovery you have failed to respond to
my criminal Discovery you have produced
no records to show that that this money
is uh is
legitimate uh what evidence do you do
now he never open ask an open-ended
question like this but in for for today
uh what evidence do you do you have to
show that this is a legitimate these are
legitimate SP so in effect at
trial the burden is very different is is
very much the same as it is
today thank
you represent thanks for taking one more
more question I'm sorry if you already
covered this but so what I'm starting to
understand is that if you want to
demonstrate
um if you if you want to demonstrate
that the funds are not related to the
crime of which you were
convicted but the funds are related to a
different crime maybe gambling or
something like that would you then have
to
is that sort of like a fifth amendment
issue where you're being asked
to uh where you're being asked to
provide information that incriminates
yourself in order to cooperate uh I
think I I don't know that I'm phrasing
it correctly but I think you know what
kind what I'm asking thank Mr chairman
representative Bing you have posed
intriguing Hy hypothet hypothetical
so police sees probable cause Criminal
Court the person is Con convicted of
drugs with a with the intent to a felony
level drug drug crime we're now back in
in civil
court and it would be wise if the person
the the convicted person wants to try to
get back his his M money to show a
legitimate source for that money and not
to show
a source that is il IL
illegal and and if the uh if the
prosecutor would uh if if the prosecutor
would say didn't this money come from
illegal gambling the colonel defense
lawyer would object to that question
because it is not relevant to the qu to
the issue of were the proceeds
associated with the drug crime for which
the person was con convicted now the
judge is still might let it in
but representative
L uh thank you sir for taking my
question thank you Mr chair just a
simple question do you think that the UN
a conviction of an underlying crime has
any bearing on where burden of proof
would lie in other words I guess in a
hypothetical conviction of a you know my
my mind a conviction of a drug crime the
underlining intent to sell um
would put the burden of proof on the
defendant to say this is legal we've
already proved by Beyond a reasonable
doubt that you were engaged in uh in
drug trafficking um and on a no charge
or innocent verdict the burden appr
proof should shift over to the state to
prove why they should somehow keep this
money
anyway Mr chair chairman Representative
no I I I stand with representative
representative uh Sylvia that the state
should always have the burden of proof
it should have the burden of proof in
the
criminal prosecution it should have the
burden of proof in the Civil prosecution
now to your The Twist at the end of your
your question in New
Hampshire the criminal conviction is a
prerequisite to the Civil for for
forfeiture it's an expensive
prerequisite because it requires going
into civil civil court it could be
handled all to get at the same process
as Maine now does
but
but in New
Hampshire the a person must be convicted
in Criminal Court should he be
acquitted to Chairman ais's question
earlier the money automatically returns
to him thank
representative
cther thank you for taking my question
um so what you just said that if a
person is found not guilty they
automatically get the money Mr chairman
representative gandler yes get it back
because it is not the fruit of a crime
for which the person has been
convicted the legitimacy of this is to
confiscate the fruit of crime it is
legitimate for New Hampshire to
confiscate the crime should not
pay if a person is acquitted there's no
crime all this all the property should
be
returned follow up okay so found not
guilty um do they still have to go into
silver
Court in order to get that
money Mr chairman rep representative
this is a very important
question in that there is the
possibility there there are not enough
cases in New Hampshire to see if this is
a problem it is a problem in other
states in my state of Minnesota it is a
94%
problem the problem in
Minnesota is that I can be acquitted in
criminal
court but if I don't engage in this
third trunch this civil litigation if I
don't answer the Civil complaint if I
don't show up in civil Civil Court I may
have defaulted in civil
court and so the benefit of a conviction
prerequisite does not acue to
motans because so many of them just walk
away from their property and don't
engage in civil civil
court we just don't know enough about
how this process is playing out in part
to I think it was representative Bin's
question in part one of the reasons we
don't
know is because this is such a
small dollar the small issues that it is
irrational for every party to litigate
all the way through to civil court and
civil
forfeiture
representative Newman did you have a
question
um I'm gonna go ahead one last question
for myself um where you've seen this law
changed um similarly to this have you
seen any um Federal implications in
other words I I I foresee IRS
involvement in unclaimed taxes from um
money that was
returned Mi M Mr chairman
uh I have not seen any change in the way
in which the federal
government uh the the federal government
engages in its
work on forfeiture I think the next bill
is no that was in
judiciary there is another bill that
representative Sylvia has has advanced
that deals with with the issue of New
Hampshire's
jurisdiction versus Federal Drug jur
jurisdiction and the connections between
the the the the two uh the treasury
Department is involved in some federal
forfeitures mostly it is the
DEA and the department US Department of
of of of Justice um I'd be happy to
explore that explain to to you and
members outside what representative
Sylvia's other Bill does that draws
protects New Hampshire's sovereignty
more as it relates to interact
interactions right okay there being no
further questions thank you very much
for your testimony thank you Mr
chairman and he
left uh uh representative Conley
oh oh Ross
Conley there is a representative com I
got a little confused there uh thank you
Mr chairman members of the committee for
holding this hearing today just for the
record my name is Ross Connelly I'm the
deputy state director for Americans for
Prosperity and I'm here to voice our
support for HB 1296 I'll try to be brief
just uh attorney m grath covered a large
amount of your questions so just want to
give our top line of of why we support
this bill it simply corrects uh language
in our drug forfeiture statutes to
ensure the burden of proof is on the
state and not the defendant uh
foundational principle in our legal
system is innocent until proven guilty
the state should have to prove the guilt
of the defendant uh as the law currently
stands an individual who is suspected of
a drug level felony drug level crime uh
would have to prove to the state that
those assets were uh were innocent of
that that crime and and we believe it
should be the other way around the state
should have to prove the guilt of those
those assets um and just to be really
clear because there was a lot of
questions about this from previous
speakers this this bill does not change
the way policing is done in New
Hampshire whatsoever police can go and
seize seize assets at their discretion
using profitable cause uh this has to
deal with putting the burden on the
prosecutors or County attorneys uh in
order to Forfeit that property uh to the
state's possession uh so this small
change as attorney McGrath
mentioned is is is just a small
correction to make sure that we're
protecting property rights in due
process uh and and for these reasons we
encourag the committee to to move this
bill ought to pass and I'd be happy to
take any
questions representative
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question um I appreciate that
you refer to it as a small
correction um and I'm curious if you
have any commentary
on I mean you look young so maybe you
weren't there when they uh set this up
in the first place but um would you
happen to know anything about the
reasoning that went into establishing
the law as is um because a small
correction but years
later makes me
wonder what the thinking was at the time
and why things went on for so long
without any any changes thank you thank
you for the question representative uh I
I am young and maybe not as young as you
think but I I uh I I was not there when
this was originally done but I I can uh
imagine that this would uh decrease
workload for for obvious reasons if the
burden of proof is on the defendant the
the the burden of all the work is on the
defendant uh so it it would obviously uh
make things easier on on county
attorney's offices but that's just
speculation uh we can just say that the
the impact of of this bill is is a real
distrust in in the criminal justice
system the the Civil civil asset
forfeiture in general and asset
forfeiture uh are are one of the
if you ask you know look at polls ugab
has done polls on this that that show
that an enormous majority of the country
disagrees with civil asset forfeiture
and and and this ties in with that where
uh the state must have to prove the
guilt of of an asset just as they have
to prove the guilt of a
defendant representative Klein Knight
thank you thank you chair
um I asked this of the previous one of
the previous Witnesses um do you think
that the use of body cams would solve
this
issue thank you for the question
representative I I don't know if it
would solve this issue I I think this
bill would probably go a long way
towards towards correcting uh this this
issue uh we did at AFP we supported the
the uh bill from last year the leak
commission that that did give funding
towards body warn cameras we we think
that's an important tool to to hold law
enforcement accountable uh but but we
think this this little correction of a
couple sentences in the law would go a
long way towards shifting that burden
and and correcting uh the
issue there being no further questions
thank you for your testimony thank you
very much the chair recognizes uh Bill
Wright is that deputy
sheriff oh the the sheriff
pardon
me not my County chair thank you
Representatives thank you I'm Bill
Wright I'm the sheriff of belnap County
I've been a law enforcement officer here
in the state of New Hampshire for over
years uh I'm in my first term as Sheriff
previous to this uh I was the bellnap
County drug task force Commander I ran a
a regional drug task force uh throughout
Bap County I'm going to keep this short
because I know that uh the Lieutenant
from NASA had covered a lot of the
points but there's a few things that I
heard during testimony here that I think
uh you need to hear it from somebody
who's done a regional task force and has
been uh boots on the ground when it
comes to uh drug trade first and
foremost the funds that we're seizing
from these people they're actually drug
dealers they're people who are actually
dealing drugs these are not uh you know
there was questions about somebody
coming across the the Border in Maine uh
to Hampshire and and money being seized
well sorry but there's got to be a Nexus
to the drug trade that is part of that
and that comes in with uh it has to be
combined facts and circumstances that
lead us to believe that so uh the next
thing is uh when it comes to search
warrants I don't want you to be misled
that every seizure is based on a search
warrant because that is not true we
seize money uh when it comes to drug uh
sales distribution
trafficking um
in in any other form of of drug sales
related uh investigations by uh contexts
that we have uh consent searches um car
stops that uh that are that we see
things in plain view again it's based on
the facts and circumstances that lead us
to believe that these uh proceeds are
connected to drug sales distribution uh
manufacturing trafficking so on and so
forth as listed in the
law
the burden of proof as it relates to um
any of these cases whether it be a civil
forfeiture or conviction on a criminal
case is the burden of the state so
whether it's preponderance of evidence
or Beyond Reasonable Doubt the burden is
is based on the state so we do have to
prove and there are processes in place
now on open source which Google or
whatever platform that you use you can
look up the the New Hampshire AG's drug
task uh the New Hampshire
AG's uh drug forfeiture and asset uh
processes so there are processes that we
are required to do as law enforcement in
order to seize funds or property as it
relates to drug uh related
offenses the burden of proof again
preponderance of evidence as it relates
to a civil case or civil
forfeitures there is a process there if
I sees money based on a drug
investigation and I believe that it has
to do with with these uh types of cases
where it's drug sales drug
manufacturing I in return uh have to do
a process so I have to give a s-day
letter to the to the uh defendant and
let them know that this is my
intent the burden is on them to file
then the paperwork to say that they want
to contest that and that's where we
start the process for a hearing for a
show s uh show of funds
sources then the burden is on them to
bring in a pay upub or whatever they
want to say is that's their money and
again in today's technology world uh
it's very simple uh for them to do
that a few things that um that also were
stated We There was talk about
convictions and process and all that
there are times where we seize funds
from a person we seize drugs from people
and we know it's in relations to a a
drug sales case not all cases are before
the courts and some of those reasons are
because maybe somebody became a
Cooperative source for a larger uh
investigation that's for the betterment
of the community and they never get
charged or convicted of the original
offense that we were uh targeting them
for but the proceeds that were uh taken
from them during these investigations
and sometimes substantial in bnap County
we've had several cases over $10,000 in
cash for people who have not had a job
in several years so that money is then
we go through the Civil process and that
money is forfeited to the
state which depending on um well on at
our state here 45% goes to the local uh
entity that did the investigation 45% to
the Attorney General's office and 10% to
Department of Health and Human Services
so that money is is divided
up the burden of proof would be on that
that person to come in and show the
source of funds and that's a very small
burden because I already had to show the
burden of why we were taking it in the
first place and we do that through
reports and and through testimony when
it comes to the putot
process striking out this language um if
you have a drug dealer that has their
drugs located in one location and then
the proceeds are uh in an out building
or or perhaps hidden somewhere else
within the house that could be a problem
uh for us to be able to connect it to
because now it's saying it's not with
the drugs it's not drug money well that
we find is untrue and and based on uh
training and experience we can tell you
that it's hidden all over the place
sometimes we get there the drugs are in
the safe and the money is just strewn
all over uh the house um I have several
photographs on my phone if you really
want to see them so again when we start
looking at the Civil forfeiture part of
it we don't just take money and then
they don't get it back unless they prove
it
that's there are processes in place and
and it's up to them to do this and I
don't know where the numbers come up um
for uh there was a gentleman that
testified earlier about uh $300,000 in
the state of New Hampshire what have you
I don't I don't know where those uh
seizures I don't know where that uh
Source comes up with where police
operate based on evidence uh where
evidence and facts type people so I
don't know where that comes from but if
it's if it's such insignificant money as
stated previously
then why is it a problem with the way
that we've been doing it and the
processes that we've been following with
the New Hampshire AG's uh
guidance take
questions representative
Bert thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for taking my uh question could you
explain
why
AFP Mr graph's group in 45 other states
are are wrong for bringing this bill
forward I cannot tell you why they're
wrong I can tell you why it works here
in New Hampshire so we we you cannot
compare uh even police you cannot
compare how we police here in our state
to any other state so we're very unique
to what we do and uh we do give money
back I don't know what other states do I
don't I don't police in other states and
um I I honestly can't can't answer that
followup follow up thank you Mr Mr
chairman and thank you again for taking
my
followup if my understanding is correct
that you all you do go through a
process to keep that
money so if that's the
case why would this bill hurt that
process that's already in place well as
stated previously during testimony uh
why don't the police just go and and ask
for the W2s or why don't the police ask
for you know um bank statements and all
that so if a person can simply say no we
do not want to infringe on their right
to to say no the problem is is that when
you start looking at getting a search
warrant uh you're building that based on
probable cause to say that that specific
dollar bill that we found in this stack
of money that was found during a drug
raid was in fact uh money that was used
during a drug transaction for for this
specific thing I don't think that we
could we could go with a search warrant
and actually physically say that that
specific $1 bill was specifically used
to purchase or manufacture or traffic
drugs within that but as a totality that
money was used in totality to do that
type of activity so a search warrant is
very
specific thank
you any further
questions thank you chair uh thank you
officer for taking my question um has uh
this process at all have have has
anything significantly changed in the
last 20 years um from doing drug
forfeitures yes so um so a lot of County
attorneys no longer want to go through
the criminal process as to um utilizing
the seizure money that we seize during a
during a vent and use that as part of uh
negotiated plea agreement um because
it's been questioned as to whether or
not that could have been a uh a a payout
or payoff uh to either reduce um a
charge or or it just gives the
impression that it's it's not there so
so as it relates to that we are not uh
going that route because there is a
separate process for the Civil civil
portion
followup yes just one okay thank well
with that being said and you said to go
online and look at the uh attorney
general's asset forfeiture materials
this hasn't been updated since June 26
2007 yes that's the one that's online
that's the practice that we still
do so between that time there there
there had to have been enough
opportunity for people to challenge our
processes between then and
now representative years that that
question would be more appropriate to
the attorney general I think who manages
that page and not the sheriff um any any
further questions for the
sheriff thank you for your time thank
you
sherff that's it
right okay there being no further
Witnesses I'm going to go ahead and
close the hearing
on
Bel and
okay at this time we now open the public
hearing on House Bill
1493 I apologize to the representative
that we are behind schedule In fairness
of was your bill
that thank you Mr chairman and uh for
the record um representative Mike Sylvia
from uh
belnap 6 representing belnap 6 town of
Belmont um passing around a sample sheet
from uh The Institute for justice uh
taken from
their uh report in
Minnesota which shows a sample of the
sort of uh data they collect related to
this
bill um so I'm uh pleased to introduce
today HP
1493 a bill which will clarify reporting
duties of the Department of Justice as
it relates to seizures and
forfeitures over the years the
legislature has sought to assure that
our citizens are protected from unjust
property
deprivation one of the keys to
understanding whether or not there might
be a problem was found to be a lack of
reporting data which is collected by the
department and made available in a
report will serve as a useful metric in
assuring our citizens of being being
treated
fairly in
2018 SB 498 was passed by the
legislature and signed by the governor
unfortunately the reporting which was
required has not been
provided this bill seeks to address
possible barriers in providing much
needed data with minimal burden on the
department as it stands now there there
are two reporting
requirements this bill consolidates
reporting under RSA 617 col12 and
repeals the report under RSA 318b colon
17f I hope this bill will be accepted as
an important measure bringing
transparency to seizure and forfeiture
data i' be happy to answer any questions
and remember the experts are behind
me
representative
pantelakis thank you for taking my
question but I would like to know what
the comparison is of from Minnesota to
New
Hampshire that is a great question uh so
for years under
318b the reporting requirement was
related to the drug a asset forfeiture
fund and that was an annual or biannual
report uh which really just listed the
uh amount of the fund its balance and
how much was uh put out in Grants it was
very uh
minimal um and didn't provide any
information on specific
forfeitures um if one requested from the
Department you could get a report that
um listed uh forfeitures after they were
all complete so going through the
process and going through court and and
finally made official and that would
list uh perhaps cars or money that were
uh forfeited and what department would
have uh
for received that uh forfeiture fund so
the the information that we were getting
was very minimal and doesn't really help
us um see what kind of uh issues U might
be things that need to be addressed in
in understanding uh the the scope of the
the forfeitures and
seizures second
question could you tell me if the there
was funding to the AG's office to do
this
reporting so the the data is
uh assembled uh already as I understand
it so the the information is available
it's just a matter of putting together
the
report and uh I'm I'm sure Mr mcgraph
would be uh able to provide the
information related to some of the other
states and what kind of process they go
through and and have some better ideas
of of what's involved but uh most of
this information is available it's just
a matter of assembling
it the reason I asked that question is
that we often tell the AG's office of
any Department in this New Hampshire
that we want things done but we don't
give them the funding for it so I was
wondering if this if you knew if this
was specially
funded it is not specially funded and we
did not get a fiscal note on this bill
so um I don't I don't know if if that is
problem I suppose the AG's office would
drop by and let us know about that if if
that is an issue that they're concerned
about thank
you thank you representative see no
further hands
raised
you is it repres uh the next witness
will be Dennis uh
carrian much
Mr for the record my name is Dennis
Corgan I'm a resident of New Hampshire
and I've uh worked with some of the
gentlemen um in the room here today for
several years on asset forfeiture bills
and and legislation and one of the key
things that uh has guided us is the need
toess says good quality information
about uh
the particular seizures and and
um uh properties forfeited in order to
promulgate
um
better uh approaches to to the
legislation it's really a a key
that if if uh legislator are
uh don't have that information in front
of them it may be difficult to see the
importance of the um of any reforms that
are that are
proposed in this uh Bill 1493 it seems
to me I'm not a lawyer but it seems to
me that there are really three separate
changes that are being proposed here the
one is to strike the last sentence of
318 b 17 C Roman numeral
2 um and to replace it with a a new
section
three uh it seems to me that
there's as a Layman not a lot of
difference between those two I'm not
going to talk about that change
similarly um to change the word shall to
May um is perhaps a term of art for the
lawyers to talk about I really only want
to concentrate in my testimony today
about the very last element which is the
changing of the words from the to each
and from summary data to data and what
guides these changes proposed changes is
the concept
that it's desirable um for the public to
have access
to
uh case level data so that for instance
since the average can be computed as to
what is the amount of uh of
forfeitures per case
um it's um it's possible that the uh uh
data that's being presented to us now
from the attorney general does show the
data in non summarized form that is
particularly helpful there's um an
argument that could be made that
uh not every element in the uh prescri
in the
legislation uh which prescribes the form
of the report is available in particular
the approximate value and
disposition is is perhaps properly
reported I'm not sure the type is shown
whether it's a cash or automobile or or
these sorts of things and these um
details are available reporting and in
different
jurisdictions uh thank you for your time
uh I know we're running behind so would
just like to um indicate willingness to
answer any questions or
maybe see no hands raised thank you for
your testimony thank
you this time the chair now recognizes
Ross
Conley
representative
Muse representative
Muse at the When I close the public
hearings remind if you don't mind could
you read off the the she the sign in
sheets members in support or
not we haven't been doing that today oh
speaking of Representative Muse just I'm
just a reminder when people sign in
support our opposition to bills we were
supposed to be reading those after every
hearing
with Collective negligence we have not
been
doing it should be there but we don't
have to you don't have to do that now
I'm just telling you in
case thank you Mr chairman and members
of the committee for holding this
hearing today once again for the record
my name is Ross Connelly I'm the deputy
state director for Americans for
Prosperity here to voice our support for
hb1
1493 uh this bill is is quite simple and
and modest it it it provides more trans
transparency in the use and procurement
of forfeitures in New Hampshire uh
currently we have a report that uh gets
sent to the governor executive counsel
and the fiscal committee uh it's quite
unclear it's it's
confusing uh and it doesn't provide the
amount of detail that would better
inform legislators and government
officials into making uh decisions uh
about forfeiture in New
Hampshire uh we often get ranked here in
New Hampshire as first in Freedom uh one
of the areas that we certainly are not
first in is is government
transparency and and we view that this
bill will will certainly help to uh to
give more transparency and to forfeiture
proceedings answer a lot of these
questions that we've been hearing over
the past two bills uh and the other bill
in in uh Judiciary and and uh having
more you know un unleashing that veil of
government and having more
uh information to the public so that
they can be better informed is always a
good idea it builds trust with the the
public and we believe just these these
few changes to the current statute will
provide a a better look at at what uh is
happening with forfeiture in New
Hampshire
uh I'll be brief and just leave time to
answer any questions since attorney
McGrath behind me uh has a lot more of
the individual detail of what currently
in the report and what changes this
would would make but it the real message
is that this provides more transparency
and will better inform uh both the
legislature and the public in decision M
making in the future and it should not
take up an enormous amount more time
since they already have to create a
summary of the existing data uh in
current law so it would probably save
them time if anything in the Attorney
General's office
representative pakis thank you Mr
chairman did you say that there was a
report that went to the governor the
executive
Council yes so the current uh statute uh
if you look at at at the bill language
that it uh the Attorney General shall
report 60 days after the close of each
fiscal year to the governor and councel
and to the fiscal Committee of the
general court a detailed accounting of
the grants provided law enforcement
agencies yada yada y they they they have
to provide this report to the
legislature governor and and executive
counsel we just believe that the detail
in that report is not uh clear and and
uh can be confusing to read and not
detailed in a way that actually gives a
look of what is being done correctly and
and what might be uh be areas of
Correction in in for forfeiture
proceedings thank
you the W the witness is excused thank
you very
much the member of the public is excused
excuse
me that
happens this time the chair I recognizes
Lee
mcrath Mr chairman members of the
committee thank you for the opportunity
to testify in support of this legisl
legislation uh let me answer
representative
public thank
you in Minnesota the state attorney the
the state auditor is responsible for
publishing every year
individualized line by line forfeitures
for every type of asset that has been
seized so all
8,000 forfeitures in in Minnesota are
reported on a line by line line property
by property basis and she and she has
absor and she has allocated a general
allocation for the running of her office
when this when that reporting
requirement was implemented in 2009
there was no incremental funding going
to her her office she absorbed the the
costs of of that in her in her budget
I was just asking the comparison of the
state New Hampshire's very small
Minnesota's very it
is Mr uh Mr chairman this is not once
again if you if you would indulge me
this is not a burdensome requirement and
if I may I'd be happy to distribute I
have three copies of I have copies of
the last three reports and
the Attorney General is reporting on a
line by line ba
basis
uh you may pass them around line by line
line basis but what this piece of
legislation would do would would would
add an element to this
reporting it would add the element of
the type of property and the type and
the value of that type of
property far so you can see that here in
the Minnesota
report the
the a 1995 Chevrolet Lumina was sold for
200 and was forfeited for $291
one so this what this build does is
change New Hampshire's reporting from a
cash flow system and you will see in the
in the in the reports that that when
this bill was modified in the Senate a
few years ago from representative
Maguire's origin uh an original Bill and
turned into a a reporting bill in the in
the sen
Senate it
was ambiguous to the the type of element
to be reported and the and the Attorney
General reasonably reasonably has
interpreted the statute to be a cash
flow statement how much money seized how
much money forfeited how much money
allocated along the the state's 45 by 45
by
10 for
formula the incremental the small change
would be to convert to add an element
about property
why this is why this is worthy of your
consideration it is worthy of your
consideration because in states that
have a that report on a property basis
you can see just how modest the
forfeiture is in
currency so in Connecticut once again Mr
CH Mr chairman the median currency
forfeiture is
$665 in Maine it is $1,000
$670 in Minnesota it is
$57 and Nationwide it is
1,300 do
dollars that information is vital to
this committee and other legislators
because it shapes the discussions that
were raised earlier about the cost of
litigation in a civil system where you
don't have a public defender where the
Indigent don't have a public defender
secondly it
raises questions about law
enforcement's
prioritizing there is certainly reasons
to
prioritize large criminal activ activity
that is not in dispute
here
Connecticut's
665 knowing that state legislators in
Connecticut may come to a
different
conclusion Mr chairman just one other
point to this to this mod modesty
representative Sylvia resisted the
requests of a certain public interest
lawyer to adopt 30 reporting elements
like the kind that Arizona Colorado
Maryland Minnesota uh uh
and New Jersey have adopted and so once
again not 30 requirements but just a
couple of tweaks to the reporting bill
is the Sylvia style and I'm happy to
answer any questions you might have
about
that thank you if and if I just may ask
a question under Roman numeral 4 it
adopt would a change of language from sh
to May when in regards to ad adopting
rules uh what is the rationale for Chang
in that to may as opposed shall M Mr
chairman the
ration is that the Attorney General may
not have to adopt
rules to to uh to meet the
legislature's requirements he just may
have to just put out an Excel
spreadsheet with some instructions so
going through the ru making Authority
formal rule making Authority may not be
necessary representative Pratt you Andre
yes I just have a quick question all day
we've been hear about the small amount
of money that's involved in these but in
my area I'm familiar with two houses
that were taken for drug forfeiture yes
sir and uh they were loaded with money
loaded with jewels and uh diamonds and
they dig the backyard up and B even more
in vehicles and motorcycles so it would
seem like one of those a year would
bring this number up from $200 to $300
to a higher number than this and hours
go ahead M uh Mr chairman representative
yes there there there are the
anecdotal large SE seiz
seizures um and and
um but the median
seizure the median forfeiture the median
now remember not average me median the
median uh forfeiture in new New
Hampshire is 7,000
th000 so so absolutely law enforcement
crime shouldn't pay it's legitimate for
the state to confiscate the fruit of of
of crime and there will be some out
large out
outliers so you're absolutely right Mr
representative representative clein KN
thank you chair um I have the same qu
similar question to chairman abis on
line
14 uh changing shell to May doesn't this
make the whole entire Bill
irrelevant Mr chairman uh representative
I don't think so I hope not I don't
think so I think it's just a question of
whether New Hampshire's formal
administrative law as it relates to
promulgating rules is necessary for the
Attorney General to meet the obligations
the renewed red and renewed obligations
that you're putting on on him and and uh
and so there therefore he may he may not
have to go through the extended
administrative process of rule
promation it does not lessen it does not
reduce his obligation to meet your new
in your data
requests
thank you seeing seeing no further hands
raised I want to thank you for your
testimony thank you Mr chairman thank
you
members at this time we will
now journ the public hearing on hb1
for
e
I
yeah
e
for
it's
this
always
e
it's
no
trash
so
EV
just
for
you
e
at this time we will now the criminal
justice Public Safety Committee will
come to order and we will now open the
public hearing on House Bill
1232 representative thank you for
joining us today we do need
you never mind got the pink card there
yeah thank you Mr chairman members of
the committee um I've served on the
criminal justice committee two terms
about a decade ago and always enjoyed
the discussions here it's good to be
back um I've long been a an advocate for
fair sentencing and a transparent
criminal justice system oh by the way
sorry Mark Warden representing
Manchester w 8 hillsb 15 and uh said I'm
a advocate of Criminal Justice System
that respects our cultural norms while
also protecting individual
liberty this proposed legislation 1232
is similar to what this committee heard
last year that was HB 615 in 2021 that
bill passed the committee and the full
house before dying in the
Senate this particular bill has been
stripped down it's much
simpler and right there in the um
analysis of the bill it's correct this
bill reduces the penalties and removes
proves mandatory minimum sentences for
certain first offense drug offenses and
then on the method methodology SE
methodology section it says the judicial
Council States this bill would reduce
firsttime possession Transportation or
use of certain controlled drugs from a
class B felony to an unclassified
misdemeanor subsequent violations
meaning not your first time could be
sentenced as either Class B felonies or
an unclassified misdemeanor at the
discretion of the
prosecutor and then I can go through the
sections real quick if you'd like
section one reduces the penalty on
firsttime offenses from a felony B to
misdemeanor
if if an offender has been convicted
previously then the penalty is reduced
from Felony a to a felony b or missed
meanor they' still give them that
discretion section two the first
paragraph removes the requirement for
mandatory minimum
sentences
of this is regarding selling in area
school the second paragraph relates to
drug Enterprise leaders and removes a
25-year mandatory minimum sentence
leaving the sentence up to the
court then section three is super simple
it
repeals um penalty for schedule five
controlled drugs and Accord according to
the dea.gov website schedule 5 drugs are
defined as drugs with lower potential
for abuse than schedule four and consist
of preparations containing limited
quantities of certain narcotics schedule
five drugs are generally used for
anti-diarrheal antitussive and analgesic
purposes some examples are cough
preparations with less than 200
milligrams of Codine per thousand
milliliters such as such as robus and AC
Lomotil motofen and LCA so the main goal
here is to reduce penalties for
firsttime offenders with a goal of
reducing the backlog and the Clogg
criminal justice system and the courts
and keeping PTY uh keeping pil people
who are guilty of victimless crimes from
potentially having their livelihood
ruined and opportunities denied because
of a
conviction this topic was brought to my
attention by an assistant count attorney
in HBO County who said she was tired of
seeing so many people's lives ruined she
thought that her office should have more
discretion in prosecution she was
particularly interested in changing the
law to allow for possession of personal
use levels of fenel and heroin and as
bad as those things can be as bad as
those um substances can be they are P
pervasive and running these people
through the criminal justice system
often exacerbates the problem she wanted
the option of putting them into a
treatment program inste instead of
throwing the book at them but she felt
they they lack lacked much discretion in
the the prosecutor's office she said
they're just overwhelmed with so many
cases and while this spells in exactly
what she's looking for it is tangential
and was the impetus for this proposed
legislation we have
today with that I'm I'll be happy to
answer questions best I can and I don't
if there's somebody else justf or not
but thank you for your
attention
if if I may may ask uh when it says drug
Enterprise
leader what what would you consider that
or Define that to be I consider a drug
dealer people who somebody who's has a
lot of
uh a lot of product in possession and I
did through
the definitions and that's sort of my
interpretation of the definitions in the
statute
representative Bert thank you Mr
chairman and thank you representative
for test your testimony um you said that
it died in the
Senate was the issues with the Senate
addressed or is it we not supposed to
refer to the um the the other
body I thought that was just on the
house floor it's it I believe it applies
applies in the committee room as well
really just I've only been here 12 years
I guess thank you for question I I
really don't know the answer I'm not
sure what happened in the the other
place all right it wasn't my bill last
year I wasn't following it very closely
okay thank you thank you representative
Burke
see see no hands raised I want to thank
you for your testimony thank
you representative Conley I mean excuse
me the chair now
recognizes Ross
Conley thought I had been promoted I
haven't had lunch today so bear with me
I'm with you um thank you Mr chair
members of the committee uh for the last
time today my name is Ross Connelly I'm
the deputy state director for Americans
for Prosperity here to voice our support
for hb1
1232 as uh representative Warden
mentioned this is a bill very closely
that uh similar to HB 615 which passed
this committee last year and and uh
passed on a Voice vote out of the house
it does simplify the language where last
year's Bill addressed a lot of mandatory
maximums a lot of fines reduction of
fines across the criminal code this bill
tries to find some consensus for that
other body um that uh where where we're
focusing specifically on those firsttime
drug offenses uh we view the the current
situation where we're we're we've kind
of reverted back unfortunately the drug
dependence is a pretty personal problem
for for many Granite Staters uh almost
everyone has a connection to somebody
that has had an issue especially in in
my generation uh with with dependence on
drugs and over the past couple years
we've unfortunately gone back on on that
we're we're hitting very high uh
overdose rates once again and uh
obviously the current trajectory is not
uh working and and taking a new approach
is what we believe is needed where we we
uh take firsttime drug possession
especially uh as a misdemeanor and and
try to direct those uh those addicts
towards getting the help they need and
and that help is not in prison it is in
uh treatment facilities so that they uh
especially 90-day treatment facilities
which will help them uh get out of the
cycle of dependence on drugs sending
them to prison only creates a cycle
where uh the the famous George Jung
quote that he went to prison with a a
bachelor's in marijuana he graduated
with a a master's in cocaine I I think
that the solution is not in prison the
solution is in uh treatment and getting
the these folks the the help they need
and we believe this bill does just that
um just to answer some of the the
previous in terms
of uh section five uh that does apply to
drug dealers however that just removes a
mandatory minimum of of
uh that that's included currently so it
gives more discretion to the judge to
make a a sentencing decision uh based on
on the level of crime uh we don't
believe that one size fits all is is the
best approach towards uh addressing the
criminal code so allowing that judge
more discretion o over that uh we
believe is appropriate uh and with that
uh I'd be happy to take any
questions r pres
Bert thank you Mr chairman uh thank you
for your
testimony we just received opposition
paper to this
and I'm going to read just one line of
it and I disagree with it because I
don't think you can force anybody to do
anything um and I was just wondering
what AFP or you personally feel about
this is it says minimum mandatory
sentencing so they're opposed to this
bill minimum mandatory sentencing allow
slash forces people convicted to get
treatment I don't think you can force
people to get treatment can you is there
a question that was the question can you
thank you for the question
Representative no I I don't believe uh
and the data does not suggest that that
forcing individuals into treatment is is
the best Avenue uh especially through
through punitive means where where
you're imprisoning them uh that that's
not exactly the best incentive towards
uh Rehabilitation and and taking the
approach of uh getting them the help
they need uh especially again especially
for those firsttime
run-ins uh is is the best opportunity to
get them out of that cycle uh so having
a mandatory minimum in putting every
single person in the same box without
any discretion to to the level of crime
or uh the extenuating C
circumstances uh is not helping
obviously and and uh taking this this
different tact will help to to correct
that thank
you representative
true thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question so would you say that
this basically is just removing the
mandatory sentencing doesn't necessarily
stop the CL of the courts with
cases thank you for the question
representative uh it would help with the
backlog to to representative warden's
point for that first section so uh
currently there's an enormous backlog
especially in Hillsboro County and
Rockingham County for these offenses and
and uh to the representative's point U
of of the Deputy County
attorney she she stated that she she
sees the same people cycle in and out
and and they're not getting the actual
help they need and uh they they get sent
to prison they go to prison they come
back they relapse they and it's that
constant cycle uh and they often turn to
selling as well to to help their habit
um the that first section will
absolutely help with the backlog uh
because if it's not a felony be offense
then you're it's not the same degree of
of case load that the county attorney's
office will have to carry uh and it will
will direct them towards actual means of
help uh and uh so in terms of that that
second section with the mandatory
minimum that won't necessarily help with
backlog but it will help with with
judicial discretion and not uh you know
putting people who may not be deserving
of a 25-year sentence or maybe they're
de deserving of much more uh that that
will be the discretion of the
judge thank
you thank thank you for your testimony
thank you very
much
SC see no more P
cards this time we will adjourn the
public hearing on H Bill
for
afteron
cool
that
at this time we'll call the order of the
criminal justice Public Safety Committee
we will now open the executive session
on house build
1493 representative B you wish be
recognized to make a
motion thank you Mr chairman I would
like to introduce uh
Amendment 2022
d00
85h so the are you making a motion of
ought to pass yes is there a second to
that
motion that has been
seconded that has been seconded by
representative
Marson and representative B I didn't
mean to excuse me for cutting you off
but you were offering an amendment as
well and
you oh yes yeah so I I did it backwards
Amendment now been offered do you wish
to speak to the amendment I'll let you
speak on
it representative L you wish to be
recognized to speak on the amendment
yes
representative
Newman was the original
statement was that was there before that
should not have been excluded that the
Attorney General was at the original
statement and then you they added that
last line was important a little bit
better correct section three prior to
that last sentence is all identical to
the original Bill we just rewrote
section three and added that last
sentence at the
end representative
Balden sorry um just for clarification
so
in the strike through
in the the the part of the bill before
the before where this would be inserted
it Still Remains a strike through is
that right and the
um basically is this just
changing the Roman 3 in the bill and
everything else in the bill is the same
or no
thanks if I may Mr chair you may to
answer that question the bill stays
identical the only difference is on
section three we're basically striking
all of section three and replacing it
with the new section three in the
amendment and the amendment the only
difference between the what was in the
original bill and the new one is that
one sentence about
confidentiality representative Marson
you recognized
is
that
representative Muse do you mind uh
reading the results of the blue
sheet for
um hp1
1493 thank you representative Muse
representative
Balden
could you also repeat who made the
motion um on this and what the motion
was the motion was made by
representative
Bert that was seconded by representative
Marson that's
correct
I I believe we can at this point we can
move the
question seeing No Hands raised
uh this is this is whether to adopt the
this is whether to adopt amendment
number
d85 if you are in support of adopting
the amendment please say yay if you were
opposed please say nay the clerk May
I'll call the
rooll
yes
yes the chair votes
yes representative B you recognize make
a motion to ought to pass as
amended yes Mr chairman ought to pass is
amended and is that
seconded that has been seconded by
representative
Welch anyone wish to speak to that
motion representative Harry
cther
are you asking me about what the fiscal
note representative
testman somewhere
today there was a spreadsheet of the
costs uh in
2020 uh of property seized this was Happ
to be by in Minnesota but
I I haven't seen anything as far as New
Hampshire in in respect to a fiscal note
I don't believe if there's any money
received through forfeiture that the
money is just thrown into a pile it is a
I can imagine that it's accounted for
and entered into a system what's being
reported is the total amount of money
not an item detailed itemization so I I
could imagine that the data entries are
already being done what would have to be
part of the report would be a more
detailed it would be the details of
those data entries which is already in
the system now whether the the software
can do that or not I can speak to
that representative l so the reporting
requirement is already there this just
changes some of the mo this modifies the
way it's done so they already the
Attorney General already has to report
on the asset forfeiture fund including
what's taken the detailed accounting of
what's taken this adds a an expenditure
I think that I'm not sure is there
before but um I again the report is
already required this changes a little
bit of the format and how it's done as
all and the inclusion model
representative Harry gther what I was
explaining was they're already entering
the data individually every time money
is received so it would be in the system
it just what's going to be part of the
report would be the detail of each entry
as opposed to just a the total
amount is my understanding what the what
this bill would do if were if it were to
pass represent of
Newman even our
testimony
as far as I'm aware there's no formal
rule that your microphone must be turned
on I strongly recommend that you turn
the microphone
on
seeing No Hands raised uh the matter
will now be put to question if you were
in support of ought to pass as amended
please say yay if you were opposed
please say
n representative
Bert representative Lang yes
representative
green clerk votes yes representative
tester
yes representative true yes
representative Pratt representative
marsten representative Harriet
gright representative
pantelakis representative o'n
representative Bourne yes representative
Muse representative Newman yes
representative Balden yes representative
con
Conley representative Klein Knight yes
representative Bradley chairman
abbis the chair votes
yes by a vote of 20 Y and zero NS the
motion passed Mr CL you wish to move
from
consent without
objection s will now close the executive
session on
on o Bill
1493 if it's not received by then
it's
this time we now call the order of the
uh criminal justice Public Safety uh
committee and we're going to open the
public hearing on House Bill thir
1360 this time the chair recognizes
representative Roy to introduce the
bill
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee for your consideration I
present um HB 1360 relative to penalties
for controll drug
violations similar to the bill we just
previously heard um in this
bill I tried to um address the issue of
making felons out of um firsttime
offenders um for simple drug
possession uh the difference being that
um we changed it to a misdemeanor but we
also kept some fine um the previous as a
law is now is $25,000 up to and anyone
who has no any knowledge of the court
system or the criminal justice system
realizes that those type of fine amount
set up defendants to fail um no one can
afford $25,000 most people I know that
have jobs and are doing well cannot just
afford
$225,000 and the people that are
involved in these type of offenses
generally aren't um
overemployed so we reduced it to
$5,000 uh as a maximum and that's
something that would still have a sting
to it but it would not be beyond the
range of possibilities for someone to
actually pay their
fine um the second part of it we changed
it from a
um we changed it from a Class A to class
B felony um it's still a felony it's a
second
offense um and I'd still be open further
to amending that if the committee so
thought that was wise um we again
lowered the fine from uh
$50,000 which again sets up a a
defendant for almost certain failure wor
such a fine imposed but we did keep a
fine if
$10,000 um and I kept this one simple um
the previous Bill we heard I I liked it
as well but I I've with our experience
in the previous year with the other body
the more complicated bills tend to get
the
more um other things get put in with
them and they don't recog resemble
anything we sent over there in the first
place so keeping this one as simple as
possible um I think it's a good first
step towards um lowering our our
incarceration rates making felons out of
uh simple possession
defendants and setting up people to fail
with fines that they have absolutely no
way of
repaying and with that I'm happy to take
any
questions representative Lang you're
recognized I I'm just questioning the
fine amount on a misdemeanor At Last I
remember the maximum fine by statute on
a misdemeanor was a misdemeanor is
$1,200 and does that in in statute
that's what we have under penalty
Clauses so does this change that for all
misdemeanors or is this we're going to
call out this one misdemeanor and change
it to a new fine
amount I would say that since it's
specific to this statute it wouldn't
impact any other any other um any other
fine
amounts
but it's worthy of checking on for
sure representative we just heard a
bill not too long ago HB 1232 is there
any conflict between the two bills that
you're aware
of other than the fine amounts were
where this bill left some fine that bill
did away with fines all together um that
bill was much more expansive in the
things that it touched
I I I'm not aware of any
conflicts thank you
representative this time the chair now
recognizes Lieutenant Bill
brigh good afternoon committee thank you
for hearing my testimony um in reference
to uh well for the record uh my name is
Lieutenant Bill BR from the New
Hampshire State Police um in reference
to uh
the the uh first offense and second
offense charges of uh certain narcotics
um dangerous drugs being uh classified
as misdemeanors instead of uh felonies
just like to point out that U many of
these uh cases uh in today's judicial
system are being negotiated uh downward
already um and changing changing the you
know jail time and fines to uh already
fit the the misdemeanor level of fenes
um that gives law enforcement and
prosecutors the ability of a negotiation
tool um another thing that uh if we are
going to
reduce um the penalties for for these
crimes I think a diversion um a
mandatory diversion um component of that
would be would be wise to have and I
understand that you can't force somebody
to um seek counseling or seek help but
at the same time um we're taking away a
deterrent that um as in if we make it
easier to um possess certain narcotics
which are dangerous in themselves
um opioids um you know a lot of these
drugs the class uh the schedule one two
and three drugs are dangerous in in
themselves and uh taking into
consideration somebody's um addiction uh
issues that they deal with I think it
would be important to uh add a component
of uh drug diversion component to a bill
like
this
seeing No Hands raised I thank you for
your testimony thank
you this time we can close the public
hearing
on House Bill
for
I can just hold it no
we we are going to hold a republican
caucus in the
room
until
2:45
e
this time we will now call the call to
order the criminal justice Public Safety
Committee we will now open the public
hearing on House Bill
1392 representative you here to
introduce the
Bill thank you Mr chairman and thank you
members of the criminal justice
committee uh my name is representative
Josh adant and I am here today to uh
introduce HB 1392 to uh a bill that we
hope will reduce uh drug penalties uh
and decriminalize drug paraphernalia um
when representative Abramson approached
me with this bill uh I was happy to
co-sponsor because I have long believed
that uh drug abuse is not an issue that
we can solve by arresting our way out of
it uh or imprisoning our way out of it
sending somebody to jail for C
heroin methampetamine doesn't actually
do anything to rehabilitate that person
it's cost to the taxpayers um and it
sets them up for future issues down the
road where um you know perhaps
Rehabilitation isn't for everybody
perhaps there are some folks that are
already you know too far gone in that
realm and will never be able to come
back um but I firmly believe that we
have an opportunity to maybe have
somebody get treatment versus jail um
it's a benefit to them it's a benefit to
to uh reducing our prison population and
it's a benefit to the taxpayers that
don't have to pay for it um I think
reducing the fines um in turning some
things into fines uh are better for
individuals uh versus steep fines they
might face that might have a similar
issue that might have a similar outcome
uh where they to go to jail um anybody
that's ever been hit with a $100 $200
$500 fine for vehicle registration um or
anything like that um knows that that
can spiral into a situation where
perhaps that person loses their vehicle
um it's a similar setup uh transferred
over to uh this issue so uh I'm happy to
be one of the co-sponsors on this
bipartisan bill and I would ask that
when it goes to exact session the
committee OTP and I can take any
questions representative
Bert thank you Mr chairman and thank you
uh representative if you look at the
back the second page p uh section five
or line five says relative to
advertising would that
mean you know we could advertise any
drug on a billboard or you know what
would that do um that I would definitely
want to follow up with the prime sponsor
on uh because honly I can't 100% answer
that with accuracy right now all right
thank
you representative Lang thank you um the
first first sentence the repeal of the
definition of drug pair failure the
repeal of RSA
318-b one
x-a um do you know if that are you aware
that that definition is used in other
statutes to make other cases things like
intent to sell showing the possession of
drug paraphernalia is part of that
making of a case without a definition
they'd have a hard time defining what
drug paraphernalia is that's possible um
that might be an area for an amendment
uh to simplify that
um if I may inquire how is there any
information on how often an individual
in New Hampshire is is charged with a an
offense
where it's just relating to drug
paraphernalia um I'm going to be honest
Mr chairman uh representative Abramson
texted me an hour ago and asked me to
introduce today so uh I did not have um
the information that I would like to
have to answer that question um but I
would be happy to follow up the
committee um after I can take a look at
that thank
you sign No Hands raised thank you
representative for your testimony thank
you at this time the chairman I'll Rec
recognize Lieutenant bill
brgh
you're doing a great
job there you go you're welcome um just
in reference to this bill uh a couple of
things that uh I wanted to provide some
information on are in my 20 years uh 20
plus years of law enforcement
um there have been very few instances
where drug paraphernalia in in and of
itself have been used as a uh chargeable
offense um to some answer your question
from earlier
um but I do believe that it would uh you
know leaving uh the definition of drug
paraphernalia uh would probably affect
or be beneficial to other statutes that
are out there as well as uh a lot of
times uh to have an extra tool as law
enforcement um is is a good thing and
just some of the scenarios that I'm
thinking of are you know a a juvenile um
juvenile who may have drug paraphernalia
in a school school resource officer
needs to have some sort of um way to to
interact with that or or take care of
that situation um so those were my
thoughts on that and then I'll notice on
uh line 16 and 17 uh of this bill where
it lists uh what seemed like the more uh
serious drugs um with a higher um a
higher fine as opposed to any other
controlled drug which is in line 18 um
fentanyl is not listed um in that list
which as uh as I stated in an earlier
testimony on a different bill um very
small amount of fentanyl is a is a fatal
dose so I only makes sense that that
would be listed along with uh the more
serious U offenses there um and that's
pretty much the testimony that I
have representative
Wallace thank you uh so you you you
oppose the bill uh yes I mean generally
as uh a representative of the New
Hampshire State Police um I'm here to
provide information and um you know
answer any questions that I can help
with help the committee with um in this
instance like I understand where
everybody is going with with a lot of
these bills um from my own perspective I
you know I like to have the tools in
place that if we need them for
negotiation purposes or or things like
that
representative Lang thank you um but I I
I if I'm not mistaken you said part of
this bill would make enforcement of some
of the drug how you how you manage and
create a drug case more difficult I
think if there's a potential for that um
if if I you know if a case is built with
you know not only the possession of the
drug itself but also with paraphernalia
that could be um you know that could be
beneficial to a case but I will say that
um you most of these you know I I've
never seen anything that has to do with
you know relative to advertising being
forced or um many of these other that
are listed
here one
followup you're recognize for follow so
again so I'm going to go just to that
advertising piece so again absent if we
pass this bill as it's written we could
potentially see on the side of a roads
buy your bong here that's that appears
to be uh what could happen
yes if I may inquire in on lines 12 to
and a lot of focus is on the
paraphernalia but from lines 12 to
15 do you have any any information or
comment on the how that would that
section of this bill would change
enforcement of the of some of the drug
laws
I have not looked at that uh section in
in that regard um so I guess I don't
have any anything to comment on at this
time thank
you representative
true thank you Mr chair and thank you
taking my question you had uh in in
looking at lines uh 16 through 19 you
had said that it doesn't include
fentanyl you saying it doesn't mention
it or you have looked at all the
rsas and it's excluding fentel from
this uh from what just looking at this
bill as it's as it's written I did not
see fentanyl listed um which in my in my
understanding if understand not
understanding it correctly um you know
that's fine as well but it it it looks
like fenel would fall under uh category
two uh any other control
prod thank
you seeing No Hands raised thank you for
your testimony thank
you
this time we will now close the public
hearing on House Bill
this time we are going to open the
executive session on House Bill
1392 representative Roy you wish to be
recognized to make a
motion I do thank you I would move in
expedient to
legislate guys been seconded by
representative
testman anyone representative Ro wish to
speak to the
motion I will
represent
justy I'm not going to get all of it but
uh I
mean even allowing road signs billboard
s with advertising is bad enough uh the
issue of essentially giving the away
drug paraphernalia as a a leveraged
school resource officers is is bad
enough but you get down further
and you look they list
a several drugs and I'm not sure if
they're all there but certainly pentos
is not there and I don't know what would
happen if something worse than final
comes on the market and so I just
think I don't know what they were trying
to do except feel good and I know Max
fairly try not to speak speak to the
motives of that but but in any case U
this has got to go we got ideal
just to raise a
concern paraphernalia argum one but if
you go from lines 12 to the end I mean
essentially if there's any type of drug
transaction or drug offense that doesn't
involve an act of violence the penalties
in change $40 per gram or $20 per gram
depending on the type of
substance I I think that's I understand
the motivation but I think that's going
too far too quickly I'm not sure if
someone interprets it any differently
than I
did I think that's a that's a extreme
direction to go from where we are now to
that one one
smooth seeing no for representative
Balden
um if I understand correctly the
concerns about
fentanyl
um my my understanding for example is
that methamphetamine came about when
cocaine was made illegal as an
alternative to cocaine that was not yet
illegal and methamphetamine presents a
whole host of problems obviously worse
than those presented by
cocaine it seems that similarly the
inability to
access less dangerous opiates has led to
the use of fental which is otherwise
regularly used medically there are
cancer patients that wear fentel patches
because of the extreme pain of the the
process uh that they're going
through um so I wonder
if there if there was less personal
Liberty at stake in using the less
Danger ous drugs if people would opt for
them more often and would be less
inclined to take risks with drugs like
fenel just a just a thought to throw out
there thank
you representative Roy you recognize um
the Representative makes a good point
however the problem with opiates is not
only are they addicting there's also a
tolerance level so even making oxycoton
um
legal what would happen is you'd
eventually build up such a tolerance
level that you would naturally have to
go to something stronger and you'd be
directed to fenel anyway um they build a
incredible tolerance quickly
so being able saying that you know well
maybe they'll stop it that it would be
great but unfortunately the body builds
such a quick resistance to it that's why
people that are on opioids prescription
opio oids generally at least once a year
have to up their up their amount to get
the same relief from the pain and the
same thing goes for people that use a
recreationally they need more and more
and more to get high eventually they end
up on fendal heroin anyway
so that's my my two SS on
that I would just point out lines 25 to
27 also would conflict with the last two
bills that
uh you
heard
being House Bill 1360 and House Bill
1232 so again it would be hard to
support
this you would have have to make an
amendment and strike that part that
language was in
Bal seeing as we can't guarantee how any
particular bill is going to pan out we
have to only vote on the bill in front
of us um but I just thought it might be
worth
clarifying um my comments earlier I I
think that fentanyl is is known to be
more dangerous than other opiates and so
I think that from the perspective of
risking your life by using the only drug
you can
find or being
sober you know I think that they would
be more likely
to um to unfortunately choose the more
life-threatening option and I would hope
that if there were less um personal
Liberty at risk a lower likelihood of
imprisonment if they choose a different
drug then um they would go for the less
uh personally Dangerous Drug at not
tolerance levels
notwithstanding thank
you this time the matter will now be put
to question if you in support of the
motion of inexpedient to legislate
please say yes if you were opposed
please say nay the clerk would not call
the
role
representative Roy yes representative
Welch yes representative Burt yes
representative Lang yes representative
green yes clerk votes yes representative
testman yes representative
true representative
Pratt representative marsten yes
representative Harriet
gright representative
pantelakis representative Hearn
representative
bour representative
Muse representative
Newman representative
Balden representative
Conley representative Klein
Knight representative
Bradley chairman
abis the chair votes
yes vote is 17 to one and three not
VES you have an objection to
consent representative Roy moves for
consent he
does without
objection
s will you be preparing a majority
report I
will at this time we will now close the
executive session on House Bill
1392 B are we vote
like I I hope
so
fr
yes at this time we'll now open the
executive session on House Bill
1232 representative Ro you to be
recognized to make a motion I do I move
interim
study is there a
second
that motion has been seconded by
representative
Welch anyone wish to speak to that
motion uh I would say that um we will be
we heard testimony on another bill 1360
that is currently in drafting for a
small Amendment it's much simpler um it
still starts us down the correct path of
reducing the uh felony sentences without
becoming so complex as to have a little
chance of coming out the way it left
once it reaches the other
body um so for that reason I would
suggest that we interm study this and we
take up the next one 1360 when it comes
down representative
testman I was just going to ask what the
uh what the strategy was here and
basically put this on aside and take
care of 1360
with it should be coming down any
second seeing No Hands raised the the
matter now put to question if you
support the motion for interm study
please say yay if you oppose please say
nay clerk will now call the role Vice
chairman Roy yes representative Welch
yes representative Burt yes
representative
Lang representative green yes clerk
votes yes representative testerman yes
representative true yes representative
Pratt that was a
yes representative Marston yes
representative Harriet
gathright representative
panacis representative oarn
representative
bour representative
Muse representative Newman yes
representative
Balden representative
Conley representative Klein Knight
representative
Bradley chairman
abbis the chair votes yes once again 17
to one three no
votes yes you
may need
consent
Mr Ro Mr to move to for consent yes
without
objection didn't object
she without objection
okay
okay so moved this time we will now
close the executive session House Bill
representative Harry
cite 17 to
one oh 1392 yeah 17 to1 also 17 to one
171 and three no
votes representative testman do you wish
wish to draft a majority
report interm study of of house Bo
1232 thank thank you thank you
representative
tesman yes you do
representative recess we'll stand in
recess
for
to 3 to to
3:30
e
at this time we'll call call the order
of the criminal justice Public Safety
Committee and we will now open the
executive
session on House Bill
1360 I understand that representative
Roy wishes to make a motion that he'll
someone like to make that motion on his
behalf that would
be he makes a motion of um a to pass
with
Amendment and is something with
yes
and representative are you recognized to
make a
motion and I'll
second and that has been seconded by
representative
Bert and your offering an
amendment clarifies
202200 87h you wish to speak speak to
your motion the amendment yes thank you
first yeah 88h Hotel um so after
discussion during the hearing um we
there was some discussion about the
fines and um representative Lang pointed
out that
um these fines are not the standard
fines for felonies and misdemeanors in
our statute they had been at some point
in the past artificially enhanced
um 50,000 and 25,000 are not the fines
um that are defined in statute for every
other felony Mr meor um so what we did
was we just took out the number amounts
so that is up to the judge to decide the
fine based on the existing statutory
fines for misdemeanors and
felonies um which are $1,200 for a
misdemeanor is that
correct
representative Lane you wish to be
recognized correct thank you so for um
correct for a misdemeanor depending
whether it's a or b it's a $1,200 fine
,000 f $200 penal assessment for an A or
for B B misdemeanor it's $1,000 fine Max
or a violation it's a $1,000 Max so this
would put this law into alignment with
our standard fine and penalty schedule
rather than any special enhanced
penalties thank you
and that was all I had for the
amendment seeing seeing no further hands
raised the matter will now be put to
question if you are in support of
adopting amendment number 2022
d00
88h please say a if you opposed please
say nay the cler will now call the role
Vice chairman Roy yes represent Welch
yes representative Bert yes
representative Lang yes representative
green yes clerk votes yes representative
Testament yes representative true
representative
Pratt representative marsten yes
representative Harriet
gathright representative
pantelakis representative
o'n representative
B representative
Muse representative Newman yes
representative Balden yes representative
Conley representative Klein Knight
representative
Bradley chairman abbis chair votes
yes 18 to nothing three no vot three not
voting the the motion to pass the amend
or to adopt the amendment is passed
representative Roy you wish to make a
motion of ought to pass as
amended that motion has been seconded by
representative
Bert any additional wish to speak to
your motion or any additional
comments uh no negative I think at this
time we've pretty much discussed it um I
don't have anything to add someone else
may
it's courtesy to the two members that
walk walk into the room representative
Ro do you mind just explaining the the
motion that is pending
sure um the the pending motion is an
amendment to HB
1361 no excuse me
1360 and it
is amendment number
0088 after the um after the hearing um
and some discussion we decided that
rather than set specific fines um
looking at the statute as it is um in
our criminal statutes felony and
misdemeanor already have uh assigned
fine amounts and at some point in the
past they were inflated specifically for
drug crimes to $ 25 and
$50,000 so we thought it best to just go
back so that it fell in line with the
rest of the statutes for felony
misdemeanors which are substantially
less um so we took the fine amounts out
and it's up to the judge on what amount
he would like or she would like to
impose and we just pass that Amendment
17 to
zero 1 18 to 18 I stand
correct
and the current motion is all to pass as
amended please State your point of order
representative
true
yes the the the question has not been we
haven't moved the question yet so
therefore the if the members in this
seat once the questions moved then
they're committed to
vote this time will matter the matter
will now be put to question if you in
support of the motion of ought to pass
please
say off the pass as amended please say
yay if you were opposed please say
nay Vice chairman Roy yes representative
Welch representative Bert yes
representative Lang yes
representative
green clerk votes yes representative
testan representative true
representative Pratt representative
Marston representative Harriet
gaite representative
pantelakis representative o'n
representative
bour representative Muse representative
Newman yes representative Balden yes
representative
Conley representative Klein Knight
Bradley chairman abbis chair votes
yes 19 to Zer two not
voting move move to
consent representative Roy thank you
this time we'll now close the executive
session on House Bill
at this time we will now open the
executive session on House Bill
1361 recognize representative Roy to
make a motion I would like to move
amendment number
87 H is that right on HP 1361 so you're
Mak a motion to pass and you wish to
offer an amendment is there a
second that is pass out that is seconded
by representative
true representative Roy you wish to
speak to your amendment I do thank you
um as I um said during the introduction
of the bill
this creates a separate um charge for
anyone
importing drugs controlled substances
into the state of New Hampshire for the
purpose to
sell um the amendment changes the
original bill in this amendment totally
eliminates cannabis type drugs from the
bill um the reason for that being there
are surrounding states and there are
issues regarding how much someone can
possess underneath the medical exception
in this state versus other states and
there are also different cannabis
products such as Edibles and such um so
we felt it best to just leave cannabis
out of it um so the remaining drugs um
on the schedule are still there and so
what this is is you would have to have
an amount that would constitute
distribution for this charge to
apply and that's it
oh I would add one more thing as I said
um for some folks who may not have been
here I did a lot of research on this and
there are many states that have crimes
like this including California where
they charge you an extra there's an
extra charge uh criminal charge for
importing drugs into the state for
distribution so this we we would not be
by any stretch of the imagination um
breaking new ground with
this representative Colley you recognize
thank you Mr chairman this question is
for the sponsor if I may
um and forgive me if you addressed this
earlier but I and I mean this truly in
good faith I don't understand the need
for this bill would this not be covered
under a under a federal statute already
um would our existing
trafficking uh statute not address this
can you help me understand why this
particular law would be necessary and
how it might be applied would this be
tacked on to to separate drug charges
would this be a standalone if I had you
know a large quantity in my vehicle and
I was on exit 2 I I'm just really trying
to better understand it no sure and that
that's absolutely right um so the reason
for the bill in the first place is as we
all know um we have an incredible opioid
crisis in the state among other things
and we also know that the vast majority
and this is um been held up by law
enforcement and the courts the vast
majority of our drugs are coming from
across the southern border or across the
border they're not made here
manufactured here then being brought in
so the impetus for dis spill and we've
tried a million other ways to get try to
get a handle on this opioid crisis this
hopefully would be something that would
at least create um a hesitancy in
someone say from LEL or Lawrence loading
up their car heading up to NASA with a
car full of drugs this would add be an
additional charge available to law
enforcement it wouldn't be in lie of it
would be in addition to um the exist
listing and it would create a class a
felony and their vehicle would be
subject to forfeiture that they were
using to transport the drugs in and if I
can just clarified this the question
that we're going to move is whether to
adopt the amendment which is the same as
the oning bill we're just removing
cannabis from it so you may have some
issues with the underlying of the policy
as a whole but I get the feeling that
some members May least be fond of the
amendment by excluding candidates Point
well taken Mr chairman
did you see Nico there did you see
nicoa
this I don't know what the green
means at this this time the matter will
now be put to question if you in support
of
adopting amendment number 20 22-
87h please say yay if you opposed please
say nay clerk when I'll call the
role Vice chairman Roy yes
representative Welch representative Bert
yes representative Lang yes
representative green yes clerk votes yes
representative testerman yes
representative true representative
Pratt representative marsten yes
representative Harriet
gright representative
panacis representative o'hern
representative
bour representative
Muse representative Newman yes
representative Balden yes
representative Conley yes representative
Klein Knight representative Bradley
chairman abbis the chair votes yes 19 to
zero two not
voting representative roor you wish to
make a motion a to pass as
amended yes I'd like to move a to pass
as
amended representative true you wish to
second
that has been seconded by representative
true
represent wish to speak to the motion um
as as we just said that the um this
amendment pretty much replaced the
entire bill so it's the same thing we
already discussed so unless anyone else
has any further questions
or I'm good representative
Bourne thank you Mr chair um I can't
support this am this bill I supported
the amendment because it did improve the
bill but I don't think it's this bill is
necessary representative Harry
GFF
representative Roy thank you if I could
just address the the federal question
um to get the US attorney to take up a
case um is really um requires a divine
intervention is unless it's a really
really large amount um second of
all well first of all that that applies
in other words a New Hampshire police
officer would have to make a stop make
an arrest and someone would have to
reach out to the US attorney's office
and see if they were interested in
Prosecuting the case there are no U
there is no policing of the interstate
borders by federal law enforcement um
unless it's an ongoing investigation
where they're actually following someone
back and forth so it really is up to the
own States um to to try and get police
what gets into their state um otherwise
we would see a lot less drugs and a lot
more Federal prosecutions but we don't
unfortunately I agree that it would be
in an Ideal World the DEA would handle
all these and the US attorney would be
prosecuting them but it's just not the
case it's not
happening representative Lang thank you
Mr chair again you know I I agree
representative Roy that that getting a
US Attorney office involved in drug
cases next to Impossible unless you're
dealing with a truckload of of drugs um
addition to that understand that this is
a mechanism to keep people out of keep
people from trans transporting into the
state right that's the goal of the bill
is to add a penalty so you bring drugs
into the state not only going to be
charged with the drugs you're going to
be charged with the transportation of
those drugs into our state keep your
drugs in your own State you want to sell
them in your state let your local police
or State Police deal with it but New
Hampshire is going to crack down on this
and I think this protects our citizens
um from those people who would choose to
come up from different parts of the
country just to speak on that
representative Lang it's a point well
taken I've never heard of a situation
where someone
manufacturer created fentanyl in the
state of New Hampshire I feel like that
would have made the paper so that's
being imported from otate and the find
this way here and there's people
dying
so this this is the hope to deter that
representative Bert you recognize uh
thank you Mr chairman um I do have a
question what is the amount that would
have to be brought across the border you
know in order for this to kick
in
representative Roy you may respond to
that it um representative thank you for
the question it is it's really different
according to each drug how much the
threshold is for intent to distribute um
and the court has certain guidelines
they go by um where it's not statutorily
spelled out specifically like was was it
was it packaged for individual resale um
how much was it that it was obviously
not for your personal consumption so
it's a kind of a case by case b B on
each each one's
different so there's no set amount that
no no no there's there's no set amount
that would trigger it it's a it's a
totality of all the information
available you having large sums of cash
with if you have a a controlled
substance in you know a bunch of
different bags having a scale is
often a sign of it's Le evidence of
distribution of the intend to distribute
and one other question yes you're
recognized all right thank thank you Mr
chairman um on the seizure of the car is
that our ready law this just you know
keeps it in
line my understanding is that if you're
using a motor vehicle in as in the
course of using it to actually sell or
distribute drugs then it can be seize
yes yeah currently all right thank you
and and the FEDS sees that and homes and
everything
else representative
true thank you Mr chair Mr J more of a
question to you can you tell me what the
current law is in New Hampshire
for
uh intent to
distribute it's it's under the chapter
that's actually listed uh 38 318
uh B but I just explained that it's it's
a totality of the circumstances they're
not going to just Define it specifically
as what
constitutes possession with intended to
distribute what it is is that you can
have a very small amount of a controlled
substance but if you have a scale and
it's and it's in 15 or 20 different bags
that could be evidence of possession
with intent to distribute it doesn't
necessarily mean that you are but it can
be representative true thank you Mr
chair no I mean what's the what's the is
it a Class A F F is it a class B felony
in New Hampshire to be charged with the
intent to
distribute um repres representative TR I
mean representative Ro you may respond I
have um just been informed that it is
already a Class A so this is not
a intend to distribute as a Class A
right
now representative Conley thank you Mr
chairman and I'm glad that the
representative mentioned that so it's
already a class a
felony to have a certain quantity of
drugs with the intent to distribute
hitting someone with a second felony I'm
not sure what the net effect of that is
um I I really do believe this is well
intentioned
um but it's already covered under
existing statute it creates a mandatory
minimum that that uh members of both
parties have worked to get rid of and
remove um and it's I think vague on
substance we just learned from the
chairman that even a small substance of
this could trigger this uh under the
statute and as I read it it would need
to already be paired with an existing
class a felony so um with that I won't
support this um and I'll stop
[Music]
there
representative Roy you may respond um
you are correct it would be um two
felonies this is an enhancement um and
it does you're also correct it creates a
minimum mandatory um and the and you're
also correct that we are trying to get
away from a lot of mandatories but that
doesn't mean every single one and and we
have so many people dying right now in
this state of drugs that are coming
across our border um so as to rival some
of the other most recent causes of death
and those we can't do anything about but
this we can and if we can at least
discourage somebody and they say wait a
minute if I get caught going across the
border with this I'm doing five years
and I'm losing my car um I just I feel
like it's it's it's the least we can do
to try and protect our children and and
the people of the state that are dying
on a regular basis and it's overwhelming
our First
Responders and I can to speak to that
that we're based on the community that I
live in the district that I represent is
a Border Town that's not too far from an
area where drug trafficking specifically
fentanyl has been widely publicized as a
huge problem so again the fentanyl is
not made in New Hampshire I've never had
any evidence of that but it's being
brought here and imported here and that
the mere fact that you're bringing the
fentanyl to this state is what I'm
really what I'm really focusing on
me that's what's killing
people represented Balden you
recognized but doesn't this bill cover
more than fentel is that
right it does thank
you representative Lang do you recognize
so the only as a again as an element of
the crime they have to prove as part of
this transportation is the intent to
distribute right the intent to sell so
so again we're talking about commercial
drug dealers who are moving coming in
from out of state to sell to our
citizens and this law goes it would be
an enhanced penalty to say stay in your
own state do it there don't come
here representative
Newman what effect would this have on
someone who goes to Massachusetts or LEL
and maybe is user and they they be they
prepackage something am a certain amount
of maybe a stale is involed or whatever
the circumstances are that Prov that
that they would come back and then be
punished by not only felony but the
minimum
felony all of
that absolutely most egregious thing I
take care is minimum minimum penalty
just won't be able to support this
bu
representative
pantelakis
representative Conley thank you Mr
chairman very quick um the one final
point I would make is that the kingpins
the the real bad actors are not the ones
behind the wheel these are low-level
people who are not actively engaged
typically not always typically not
actively engaged who are doing the
transportation this is not going to stop
the flow of drugs into our state it is
just going to mean more people serve
more time for it while the next person
in line uh willingly grabs the wheel and
makes the next delivery and I wish it
weren't so but it
is at this time the representative true
you you are
recognized I apologize a question of the
chair because you're have a
lawyer um a class a
felony uh conviction will result in a 7
and a half year incarceration of not
more than 15
years uh and fines of up to 4,000 so H
how would this work that if
you're found guilty of importing with
intent to sell and intent to
sell you would get seven and a half
years at
least plus a minimum of five years how I
mean how would the judge rule on
that there can be concurrent sentences
consecutive
sentences I'm not sure they
canp may you may respond to that it's
it's my understanding that um on the
class felony the one that the
representative true just brought out the
first instance um it's it's not a
mandatory so it could be suspended um
there this is mandatory so there'd be no
option to to suspend it or put them on
double secet probation or anything like
that versus the other one um if they're
incarcerated they will be incarcerated
for seven and a half but it's not a
given that they will be
incarcerated representative
Balden thank you so is the Assumption
here or the hope is that that when the
um when a person is considering moving
drugs across state lines their knowledge
that it's to felonies instead of one
will dissuade the behavior the first
felony didn't do it but the second one
will is that the
Hope representative Roy May respond to
that um my no I think the hope is um
first of all the mandatory the first one
um anyone with any experience in the
criminal justice system you see um many
times they'll plead in other words
you'll arrest somebody with intent to
distribute and um uh uh the majority of
the time those first few offenses are
going to get pled down to just
possession just to dispose of the case
so they know that there's a good chance
that they're not going to do time on an
intent to distribute case unless they
have an extensive record this my hope is
that they'll say wait a minute if I get
caught with this I am doing five years
um and that will dissuade them um and
and likewise for the vehicle forfeiture
as well because a lot of times we see
people I don't want to use the word mule
but they'll get someone else to drive
them because they don't have a car or
well that person also might have a
second thought to say no I'm not taking
you anywhere because we're both going to
be five years
um as the previous Bill where we reduced
the sentence for first offenders uh
first time offend simple possession um I
think at the same time we have to
toughen up on the dealers if we're going
to we can't go easy on everyone if we're
going to try and give a break and and
look more towards Rehabilitation of
these these simple offense possess
possession offenders we have to at the
same time stem the flow otherwise it's
just going to be revolving door but
that's that's my opinion and we did hear
a testimony and I I apologize it not on
this bill but on a what one of the bills
that when you have a penalty of this
nature and someone is perhaps stopped or
arrested when they're facing a sentence
like of that nature is how law
enforcement often can gather or get
informants so that person's facing
cooperate or this is what they're going
to face so that also gives law
enforcement more to work with as
well representative
bden so I'm hearing that if we double up
on
the felonies and take their cars
they won't bring the drugs cross the
border but when they still do even
though they won't when they still do
we'll have informance and so those
people who violated the law will not be
punished so they won't do it but when
they still do we won't punish them is is
what I'm gathering here and it's just
very confusing especially considering um
what representative Conley mentioned
that these people that are arrested for
this are
typically unwitting drivers probably
trying to make money for their drug
habit and they're not the dealers
they're not the kingpins so this doesn't
seem to address the kingpins whatsoever
and it and I think overall what I seem
to be hearing is that this is an
Enforcement issue really um this is a
court issue this isn't a legislative
issue so I have concerns that this bill
will have the intended
effect just to clarify I'm not
suggesting that a person who violates
this law this law will not be punished
that is within the that's something that
the county attorney or the Attorney
General in law enfor that's between
that's out of the scope of what we're
covering here but that does give law
enforcement another tool in the overall
uh fight against the drugs that they're
dealing
with representative cly knight uh thank
you chair um
I is there any sort of data involving
how this may have impacted another state
or another state has adopted this
language and how it has affected their
prison
population I I can um I can tell you
that there are many States including
California Florida Texas that have
adopted this I can't speak to how that
would require really an in-depth study
to be able to isol out laid out what
exactly affected the population or not
or and how but I can tell you there are
other states that have
it we still have a follow follow up
thank you all with due respect to the
bill and the the sponsor um do we have
to exec today or is there more research
we can
do I think we've had a plenty discussion
on
it so at this point I think we
represented
panus my understanding this is this yes
it's targeting individuals who are
importing drugs with the intent to
distribute those drugs in the state of
New Hampshire so those drugs in all
likelihood are not manufactured or
cultivated or whatever in this state
they're brought in this state and this
is an additional penalty in addition to
possession with intent to
distribute at this at this point unless
you if you have not spoke already I
think we can now move the
question if if you in if you in support
of point of order Mr chairman you
recognized for your point of order um
it's my understanding that we can't move
the questioning committee that that's
only a motion for the floor is that
correct that's true but he can vote
whenever he
wants I I believe are you believing that
I'm what rule am I not following I don't
follow there can't be a motion for me to
for the chair to move the question but
the chair has the discretion to move the
the question at their own discretion so
as a chair of the committee I'm moving
the question is this not a deliberative
body where we
deliberate I'm I'm not following what
you asked a question about H what
discretion I have to move the question I
just answered your question so I I'm not
going to I'm going to overrule your
point of
order this point at this time the matter
will now be put to question if you in
support of the motion of ought to pass
as amended please say yay if you oppose
please say
nay Vice chairman Roy representative
Welch yes representative
burrett representative Lang yes
representative green yes clerk votes yes
representative testerman yes
representative true yes representative
Pratt representative marsten yes
representative Harriet
gright representative
panacis representative
o'hern representative bour
representative
Muse representative
Newman no representative Balden no
representative
Conley representative Klein Knight no
Bradley chairman
abbis the chair votes
yes with a vote of 12
to8 passes one no vote non voting that
is
repr Roy you you'll be preparing the
majority
report someone be preparing a Minority
Report going forward I wish for that to
be assigned right away because I spent
last fall I spent more time tracking
down the reports and it would would have
taken for me to write both of
them which
representa Balden you'll be thank
you and try to try to submit that before
the end end of the day today but if it's
not received by noon tomorrow I'm not
going to accept them because we've had
reports of a month
overdue we now close the executive
session on HB
1361 it
is well no motions needed we are
adjourned
e